three two one
hold on is it real it's live
that's it end of the world part two tim
dillon you savage
it's good to see you my friend thank you
for having me we're back kyle kalinski a
voice of reasons person who actually
understands politics that's debatable
it is debatable we'll see how much the
voice of reason i am i will say
uh i will lean towards you knowing what
you're talking about um
what's going on oh sorry so
do you do you have an opinion about how
this is
yeah do i yeah do i have a prediction
yes yes uh
it's very likely to be joe biden winning
and what makes you say this
first of all let me just let me just
make clear so you know we don't get mass
down voted i'm not saying that because i
necessarily
want that to happen i'm saying that
empirically i think it's very likely
that he's going to win and the reason i
say that is
i i actually sent this to you jamie if
you uh want to pull it up but
um when you look at the polls and i know
we get into whether or not you should
even believe the polls right right
because
26. you don't think so right well my
thing with polls i i
even have a bid on it it's like who
answers polls morons
so if you're listening to morons like 46
percent of morons believe this
but nobody a normal person with a
regular life that
hey kyle may i have a few minutes of
your time to ask you about politics
you don't say yes to that morons say yes
to that so the people that you're
polling are almost all morons
yeah or lonely or sad
or lonely or sad right it's true i get
talked to the poster nobody calls me
i'm waiting every night for a call i
want to talk for hours about and no one
cares
yeah have you ever answered a poll i've
never answered a poll no never have you
i've never been called jamie have you
ever answered a poll
not like a real one though not a real
one for kleenex
i don't know who they call and why they
i don't believe in polls and i don't
believe in nielsen families i don't
think they're real
i've never met a nielsen family it's a
good point people say they have a friend
all my friends in nielsen family
right really right so our ratings
everything's just fake
it's all fake yeah we don't know
anything the news is now we know
the news is definitely fake i'll give
you that when fake news when you
would hear fake news you'd be like
that's such an unfortunate term
i hate when people say that because you
know it's not fake you know hillary
started that right it wasn't trump
hillary was the first the original one
who said fake news and then trump took
it and ran with it and now everybody
thinks it's just a trump thing no way
when yeah she did
i think the first time that that term
came up she said something it may have
been in the context of like
oh we need to regulate fake news online
like fake news there's all there's all
these stories that blow up on facebook
and they're not true and maybe we should
do something about it and she used the
term fake news in a speech
and then after that it was trump who
started using it now everybody thinks
it's you know been him all along
interesting yeah well he used it a lot
that's for sure
i mean yeah now it's his obviously got
like a patent on it
2016 was when we first heard that term
like
that we have existed for a long time
there's been
media for a long time even internet for
a long time
relatively and yet fake news is a new
thing and
now but i used to think it was [ __ ]
i just think it was a cheap cop-out
for someone who didn't want to deal with
facts and they would just tell their
people hey this is fake news
and you'd be like but you know that's
not fake so
that's one of the reasons why i think
trump resonated is because
he would say stuff that i think people
around the country
just had a sense that he's right about
it like joe think about it
the media in this country lied us into
the iraq war
right if there was like that is the
definition of fake news not only is it
fake news but it's fake news that led to
the deaths of
200 hundred thousand innocent iraqi
civilians and thousands of our own
soldiers when you say that you don't
think they were in on it
no i don't think see the way it works is
and noam chomsky's got a book called
manufacturing consent where he really
dives into the specifics of this and
gives you the mechanics of it
but basically the way it works is the
people who
get hired at these news outlets they've
all had like the proper training they go
to ivy league schools you know they
study journalism and you only get
promoted
if they know you're really not going to
rock the boat and what i mean by that is
you basically
repeat the line that the government
wants you to repeat and so
you know when george w bush and dick
cheney were out there making the case
a good little journalist says oh here's
what the president says and here's what
the vice president says and they're
saying that saddam hussein has weapons
of mass destruction and then you had
colin powell go to the u.n and hold up
the uranium and say
i'll see you i mean what do you want to
do do you want what did they say do you
want the evidence to come
in the form of a mushroom-shaped cloud
right that was them saying we need to
act now
and forget about proving it we have to
act now and the media went right along
with them was there any
doubt that they knew that that was not
true
um i think there are probably some
people who made the argument
who were convinced of the propaganda
themselves but no the decision had been
made long before that that saddam
hussein was on a list of rogue actors
who we wanted to overthrow
and by the way that list still exists
today so all this fighting that we do
with iran
they're on the list and we want to
overthrow them as well yeah a lot of
people don't know the history of it we
want to get them back
they executed that olympic wrestler no
why did they do that you went to a
protest
oh the the iranians executed yeah he
went to a peaceful protest
and uh they wanted to make an example of
him he's an olympic hero
how did they execute him i don't know
geez i don't know but the ufc
made a push uh dana white put out a
video begging the government to please
not
did not execute him it's an
authoritarian theocracy
you know that's what happens there's no
social freedoms yeah you know the idea
of freedom of speech is
totally far in there well it's it's as
you said a theocracy like we i talked
about with
glenn greenwald too that they um they
have an extraordinary high number of
transgender
uh women because they don't allow they
don't like gay rights yeah so if you
wanna
if you're a man you're attracted to men
you you have to become a woman
right which is crazy that they're okay
with that very
in in a weird way kind of very
progressive
like an incredibly progressive state
where they're like
we'll get
yeah it's progressive and homophobic at
the same time
in a super weird way yeah this is the
[ __ ]
i mean like we're dealing 2020 and
people getting beheaded in france
for showing cartoons i mean listening
all over again
i was actually just talking about this
earlier that you know one of our top
allies saudi arabia
they still behead people in the public
square yeah you know it's and they do it
for drug smuggling
they do it for apostasy all these crimes
that are not even really crimes and
they'll kill you
that's crazy that that's happening in
2020 that's the thing that people
when people are not afraid of
dictatorships or of the governor
government running wild in america i was
trying to tell them like
north korea is happening right now
those are human beings those are human
beings that went
down a path is it likely that we'll go
down that same path no
but human beings have been going down
those paths
from the beginning of language from the
beginning of time the strong man is a
big
you know the idea of a strong man the
dictator the person i call all the shots
that's why everybody's terrified of
trump that's why a lot of
intellectuals were terrified of trump
they didn't like that language
they didn't like they didn't like what
people were attracted to about him
because they knew where that led they
did like like what was that
it was a phrase that he said once where
he was talking about uh i wish i was a
dictator it would be a lot easier
remember that i don't remember that no i
feel like i would remember that quote
yeah that's what i remember he did
something like that something like
something like that
yeah if i was a dictator this job would
be easier i think you know someone was
calling him a dictator and
he's like i wish i was addicted but
that's him lamenting
the paperwork that he has to go through
and all the yeah limiting the paperwork
the thing that drove me crazy is that
like so you had under bush and you had
under obama
um basically the expansion of the
security state and you had like the
patriot act nsa spying
all these tools that are authoritarian
tools that the government can use
and trump correctly when he ran spoke
about ending the wars
and but then he gets in power and the
wars continue
and then he gets empowered he didn't
dismantle he talks all the time about
how the obama campaign was buying on me
and i'm watching it like if only you
were in a position of power to do
something about that like disband the
nsa
but it would stop the nsa that's a good
way to get shot yeah yeah that's a good
way to get that's actually
chuck when he was on msnbc he had a
moment of honesty where he was like
you don't mess with the guys in the
intelligence agencies because they got a
thousand ways to sunday to get back at
you right yeah well that was one of the
things that he said
to trump glenn glenn glenn brought that
up with the podcast
it doesn't seem like biden is more of a
war hawk though in a weird way and kamal
is more of a warhawk it's about russia
they're talking about
trump's too friendly with north korea
he's choosing those issues absolutely
it's kind of weird i'm like shouldn't we
be friendly with these nuclear powers
but isn't that just to court the people
on the right that maybe you're
they find out no no no i think listen
biden was part of the obama
administration we don't have to guess
they continued the wars
you know what i mean and so i think
biden will continue the wars and to your
point
yes there are specific issues like
russia where what the democrats say
happens to be more hawkish
it's more intelligent the republican
side but the thing that drives me crazy
is that whenever
any of them get in power none of them
just end the wars none of them get out
of iraq none of them get out of
afghanistan every now and then trump
will fire off a tweet
where he's like you know we're getting
out and then one of the generals behind
the scenes is like no we're not and he's
like
you're right we're not i was wrong can
we afford to get out of the wars this is
an ugly question can we afford
ford to stop the wars now afford
yeah isn't it a money maker isn't that
why oh yeah well military industrial
complex
there are a lot of people that make a
lot of money from it it's a tough
economy maybe we stopped the wars in a
couple of years
i don't know i know and actually one
time on cnn it seems like an odd time
wolf blitzer actually said that to paul
or uh i'm sorry rand paul when rand paul
made that argument he was like we should
not be giving weapons to to saudi arabia
um and wolf blitzer's response was yeah
but what about the jobs
right yes he's like i mean listen i know
you don't want like
babies to be bombed in yemen by saudi
arabia but then again raytheon needs to
make some money what are you doing it's
such a dirty
game i ran into him in a hotel in vegas
does he exist as an actual person
he's a robot right he was coming he was
coming out of the elevator and i was
coming towards him and
he looked at me and i looked at him and
i wanted to go hey man can i ask you
some questions
just a few [ __ ] minutes yeah and then
i i didn't i just said hey what's up i
just got in the elevator and i went ah
you should have [ __ ] talked to me
he's what i alluded to before which is
the reason why he's on cnn for 47 hours
a day
is because that guy's not gonna rock the
boat that guy's gonna ask the questions
that the people in power want him to ask
right exactly exactly that's what's
weird about the system right
what's weird about the system when you
see people like chris cuomo
uh talking to his brother and you know
he's never going to bring up the nursing
home thing and
he was on cnn like every week yeah
you've got this one chance to talk i
mean you've got a real issue
you've got a real issue though as
serious as it gets life and death issue
and he's directly in charge of it he
could fix it and his brother's throwing
softballs talking about you know
hey remember we had meatballs the other
week with uh with the family [ __ ] guy
don't call me fredo
yeah i mean they're disgusting people
yeah um well
you know you know the fake weight
controversy i've been in involved in the
fake great controversy fake wig
controversy fake weight
okay wait because i bought into it i was
like maybe he's just really strong
i thought he was bigger than he was and
i didn't realize how hard it is to lift
a 100 pound dumbbell which sounds
ridiculous because i work out
but i don't i don't do that those kind
of workouts i'm like maybe he's just
really strong
and everybody was like you're out of
your [ __ ] mind like there's no way
are you a [ __ ] like people weren't
analyzing that like building seven like
they were like freeze frames
take a look i've talked to robert oberst
and uh
rob candy who are real those are these
guys are real strong men
you know rob kearney's like one of the
strongest maybe he's strongest man pound
for pound in his in his weight class
and then uh robert oberst is a a
legitimate giant he's like 300 plus
pounds and he's like he would have to be
one of the strongest men i've ever seen
in my life
so there's no way let me just show you i
fill in the gaps here
chris cuomo is releasing videos of
himself working out now he's a
photographer
sitting at a desk with a dumbbell that
says 100 pounds on it
where these experts are saying there's
no way it could be 100 pounds
dude you're a news guy what are you
doing like nobody wants to see you do
that but
there's a lot of weirdness too right
like how come they never brought up
those
tapes the michael cohen tapes that
tucker crossing was playing over and
over and over again where he's preparing
michael cohen for the questions that
he's going to ask him on cnn
who was preparing michael
day after day gr like going over these
tapes
because i don't know how they got the
tapes it's never been clear yeah but
it's chris cuomo
it's like i think michael cohen probably
bugged his room and taped all of his
conversations
and probably gave it to tucker carlson
like maybe he's making some sort of
behind-the-scenes deals because cohen
is you know he's been known to be a guy
who
he's trump's fixer he's a fixer yeah he
does sleazy [ __ ]
and his his thing with this was
they were preparing him for the
questions you know like
chris cuomo was telling him how to
answer the questions
right yeah he was gonna when it came to
the payoff money for stormy dan sure
which by the way you know i really think
that that's a perfect example
of a kind of politics that simply
doesn't work anymore back in like 1987
you want to have a story about like oh
the president [ __ ] a porn star or
whatever
people would be all over it and they'd
be like oh my god this is this is ending
him depends on the president depends on
the people it depends on the president
but really what trump shows
is that all it takes to override
scandals like that i'm not saying all
scandals are saying scandals like that
is you puff your chest out and you say
wrong wrong i don't want to do any of
this we're going to talk about something
else now and eventually people go
all right i think we're going to talk
about something else now it's everybody
knows he [ __ ] girls right like this is
not confusing
he ran the miss universe pageant yes
that's right yeah he's a famous
billionaire right
who's had multiple wives and you know
he's
he's that [ __ ] guy right mover shaker
guy
but the best example this is remember
when they released the access hollywood
tape
and you know he was caught on tape
saying i grabbed him by the [ __ ] i
don't even wait
and then the me i don't know if you
remember the media reaction to that but
they were all convinced like
that's it the race is over right he's
going to drop out pence is going to take
over it's going to be pence versus
hillary clinton
and his response to that i think showed
this new era of politics which is
actually
brilliant you always go on the offense
so what he did is at the next debate
he brought all of bill clinton's
accusers yeah and he had like six of
them sitting there
and then when they asked him that
question which by the way of course was
like the first question they asked him
yeah he was like listen i'm not proud of
what i said but what i said was just
words it was just words
was actions what he did was actions and
they're all right there bill i think you
should apologize to these people right
here
and what you do is you flip it and you
go on the offense and then the best
defense is a good offense and then he
made it a watch the issue is now a while
also in his case that is a really good
argument
this is a good argument it's not like a
regular person unless he's talking
about bill clinton who's married to
hillary clinton who was his opponent so
her calling him a sexual predator is
rich
i mean that that's that's right and also
let's be serious it just diverts from
what we're really supposed to be talking
about when we're discussing the most
powerful person in the world
tell me what you're going to do with the
economy right tell me what you're going
to do with taxes right tell me what
you're going to do with infrastructure
tell me what you're going to do with
foreign policy and if we're not having
that conversation i do think most
americans there's something
in them where they're just like this is
not serious you know let me ask you this
you you see you say that he should have
ended these wars he should have
disbanded the nsa i wouldn't i wouldn't
go that far just stop the spying i don't
even think it's possible
first of all don't think the president
has that kind of power i'm ignorant
technically he does
like technically he can because that's
an executive agency and he controls the
executive agency so he could
literally disband the nsa he could do
whatever he wants with any of the
executive agencies
so good luck good luck with that well
that gets back to what we were saying
before the schumer point of like no they
are going to [ __ ] with you and we've
seen that but don't you think there's i
mean
for sure some shady things have been
done
but don't you think there's some benefit
to having a really powerful agency like
the nsa that understands
how to spy on bad people and make sure
they don't get away with [ __ ] you have
due process only if you follow the
constitution and have due process but
how can you do that and still spy on
people without warrants
you gotta show evidence you gotta you
gotta show evidence to a judge a judge
will approve it
and then you can spy but the way judge
has a big mouth but the way it works now
you know fisa quartz it's just a rubber
stamp
where they say oh we want to spy on this
person they don't even look uh whatever
that's fine just go spy on them
and that's where we are where we are now
where the nsa can take everybody's
metadata
everybody's information and they can spy
on you not stop so
you know if you do it and you follow the
constitution and you follow the law
and you have you know a reason and you
follow due process well then everybody's
okay with it because that's just called
regular police work
kennedy wanted to disband the nsa right
and now he's dead yeah
no cia
military uh the intelligence gathering
capabilities to the pentagon to the
military
and kind of get rid of the cia's 24 7
unaccountable unaccountable you know
yeah
war machine look at what happened
there's probably a lot of reasons why he
was shot
i mean i mean there's probably multiple
maybe marilyn manson was pissed and
hired a hit man
yeah uh not marilyn manson oh marilyn
monroe
new conspiracy i think marilyn manson is
[ __ ] jfk
it says something nice about our country
that the deep state hasn't tried to kill
trump
i think that's like a nice thing it says
something
it says something nice he's keeping the
water he's going right
he's keeping the warship sure but i also
think it's maybe they're getting a
little softer
a little bit more more progressive
they're more progressive well whatever
it is but i think it's nice
because they were killing everyone
remember bobby kennedy jfk
mlk i mean it was just a period it was
just through it spraying bullets at
everybody and now
it's kind of a light touch well we'll
say he's a soviet agent or will
did you read that book that i told you
about chaos that tom o'neill book
i read a few chapters of it's amazing it
gets into that
it gets into bobby kennedy at the end
yeah like that that uh
jolly west guy the cia yeah that guy
was involved with jack ruby that guy was
involved with
robert robert kennedy talked about it on
the uh mike tyson podcast
really yeah yeah they have trait
uh record of all eight bullets that got
fired out of that gun and
they weren't fired at uh robert i
believe is the way he
that whole arrow was just a lie like
that whole arrow
yeah a lot of lines a lot of fibs a lot
of hits you know but eventually vietnam
ended
and we're still in iraq we're still in
afghanistan yeah you know in vietnam we
talk about it like it was such a long
war it wasn't [ __ ] compared to
afghanistan 2001 we started it 19 years
who is still in afghanistan we still
have about
i want to say about five or six thousand
troops there wow okay because i have
friends that have done like three tours
there and now they're back
like people have gone three or four
tours entire you know
chunks of their life in that war people
forget it's even happened
i covered a story on my show there was a
father and a son there was an article on
some military outlet
where the dad is talking about how now
my son is going to the same war that i
fought in
and you know i pulled up a cartoon that
was drawn in like oh seven or something
where somebody made that joke
joking around like yeah oh father and
son going to the same war then it
happened
yeah yeah it's really disturbing it's if
you know
if you're into it maybe they like it i
mean that certain families want to be
some people just want to go to war i
have friends that are in the military
because they like
to kill and they want they need to go
kill somewhere
that's lee it's true well don't you
think they think they're doing it for a
good reason
no not not the people on the island that
i know
the people from long island and boston
that i know no they just
they anything's a good reason for them
you know
yeah you gotta have a sting for people
right there's getting you know more
about violence than anybody
there's got to be something where
violent people can go and be
about violence where they're like you
know like violence has no place in our
society and they
they think that the ufc is bad for our
society i'm like
those are some of the i've seen so few
brawls at ufc's it's it's amazing
i've been to hundreds of those things i
don't know how many times i've ever seen
a fight like maybe three
four times never right and those are
drunks right you know
but something like that's a good outlet
for the kind of instincts that you're
talking about
you know it out of the system i gotta
give a [ __ ] if you want to voluntarily
have a duel like it's the old west
you know go out there and walk 10 paces
and turn around and shoot presidents
have done that that's right
we've had presidents that had drones
while they're in office yeah burn burn
uh hamilton right
crazy show let me look that one up for
you i'm pretty sure it is though
yes i believe it's them what's really
crazy is how recent that was
that was pretty it was not that long ago
when people are [ __ ] in outhouses
and wearing cameras
talking about beating each other up like
we could see it going
back to that how long would that last 12
seconds it would be
amazing they both gas out the burr
hamilton duel look at that
oh so the vice president of treasury
what
oh my gosh that'd be like early in the
morning of july of the 18th
11th 1804 wow that's like 20 years ago
mike pence and steve mnuchin dueling
today the culmination of a long and
bitter rivalry between the two men
wow burst shot hamilton while hamilton
hamilton shot broke a tree branch above
and beyond burr's head
hamilton was carried to the home of
william
bayard jr hamilton died at two o'clock
the following afternoon
wow that's heavy
that's that was back before the you had
people doing it before you had the
agencies and underground people
yeah just muskets and just dudes being
dudes
if they want to do it isn't that the
ultimate like you know libertarian
argument like go ahead it's not [ __ ]
bothering me
i believe there's places in america i
think arizona might be one of them where
you can still engage in a duel
because i believe i've read a story
about a cop
who uh had a duel with a guy who was
[ __ ] his wife
yeah a duel yeah aka
she shot him that was back in the head
that was why it was controversial but i
think they had
you know you know like some places have
mutual combat laws like seattle has a
mutual combat law
where the cops will stand by like if two
guys want to fight
oh is that why like the proud boys named
people when they go at it in seattle the
cops don't do anything
i don't know okay i think they're just
overwhelmed i get it yeah
but i think in seattle in particular i
know i want a fight you can stand by
yeah there was a guy named phoenix jones
he was uh
um [ __ ] forget his name but he was
he called himself phoenix jones but he
was an actual mma fighter
who would go around and he his brother
was a fairly successful
mma fighter and he would go around
wearing a superhero costume
and yeah and literally fight crime
like if you would see people doing
things you stop people and there's a
video of him
with his superhero costume beating the
[ __ ] out of somebody
because some guy decided to fight with
him and the cops were literally standing
there
while this one guy's bouncing on the
tips of his toes
on the balls of his feet rather moving
leg kicks the guy leg kicks
the guy again you're like oh my god like
this poor bastard some
poor drunk is just getting lit up by a
guy who's a trained mma fighter with a
superhero costume on
at what point do they step in i mean
they'd have to step in at a certain
point
he's about to beat him to death probably
right but but the problem is
on the concrete any punch could result
in your death because if you fall and
bounce your head off the thing you could
easily
be over yeah that's right by the way i
almost did that today
you almost fell i did fall but i almost
hit my head i'm lucky i didn't
what happened i was on one of those
stupid uh uber scooter things oh no
yeah it was bad oh no and then as i was
falling i was like i'm [ __ ] 32 years
old what am i even doing here
well not only that you're about to do
the most important podcast of your life
this is when trump wins his re-election
people would have enjoyed it if they saw
giants guards actually got one here kyle
was telling me how trump's not gonna win
it it sounded kind of
persuasive okay give me the give me the
rundown right because i'm not it's not
me i'm just relaying the information so
it's okay i know you hate them
i do but i hate biden too jamie i dm'd
you this if you want to pull it up but
um the first thing here is this is
basically every single presidential
election and where the polls were
going into that day and basically
the hillary clinton donald trump
election was the only election where
somebody had a four-point lead as
hillary had and then she lost
the electoral college she won the
popular vote but she lost the electoral
college
the case with gore as well um with gore
well he was bush was up versus gore 3.6
percentage points didn't gore win the um
he did a popular vote winning it by a
razor thin margin but the point is the
polling
going into that day was bush up 3.6 look
at this um
2020 biden up 8.6 wow that's high
and then clinton three points 3.9 obama
0.3 in 2012
uh obama 6.7 what 2012 he was only up
0.3
he ended up winning the electoral
college with i want to say about 330
electoral votes
um but yeah he was up nationally he was
only 1.3 why was he
so low that was against mitt romney i
was against mitt romney yeah i have no
idea i thought he cruised through that
well he did in terms of the electoral
college numbers but nationally it was a
very even race
which is why they treat it as such
throughout the election polling
right that's the national polling which
that's so low
yeah that one is a little bit surprising
i would have guessed he would have had a
five-point lead or something like that
but anyway as you can see here
like we have to go back to what uh
clinton in 96 when he absolutely
uh landslided i think it was dole in 96.
and he got to go back to reagan in 1984
plus 17.7
and and i guess hw bush as well plus
10.1
like basically yes the the national
number
is not the most important because the
electoral college is what matters but
biden has has never been down in a in
the national number at any point
throughout the race and then when you go
to the swing states
uh trump's path is just so razor thin
where he can't have anything go wrong
for him
so he needs to win flor he has he has to
win florida or he's done
if he loses florida it's over tonight
isn't florida filled with old people
though
yeah i was just i was invited now was
winning on
i was in florida and i'm telling you
right now they love trump and florida
but there's a lot of signs there's a lot
of enthusiasm yeah and it is
it is a legit swing state like i think
the average is biden's only up like two
points there
in uh for the race but it is a genuine
swing state but he's winning now with
old people biden is he's winning with
that demographic
because the way trump handled code
probably because of covid that's right
so they're scared
right i don't know what their reasoning
is but i just know that that's what the
numbers are showing right now what could
have been
been done differently well we've
actually talked about this quite a bit
listen my i'm not a doctor i'm not an
expert wait i'm just an idiot you know
i'll go get my medical degree you got
our food uh do you want to bring it in
here yeah [ __ ]
um i see you over there eating you're
out of your mind i saw you pull those
bags
we ordered mcdonald's uh in tribute to
donald trump this is his last election
honestly this is a tribute to me because
i eat mcdonald's probably more than
anybody else
whether he wins or loses he's done a lot
of great things to unite the country
whoa i mean i think that we all have to
remember that this is going to be quoted
on someone's blog tomorrow
the same people that called you a uh
far-right conspiracy theorist i can't
believe it who called you that
i don't know the text a lot i get people
with pink hair and
yeah people that are angry yeah the same
people that were uh saying that we had
an
anti-vaxx message in the alex jones
podcast listen you guys were really
trying to
fact check everything that was pretty
clear to me well not only that the thing
that he said was absolutely true the
thing he said about
the one vaccine that uh bill gates is
promoting
that has 80 of the people that took it
got sick yeah but
is he i'm sure he he is he against all
vaccines no he's not
no no the thing is like look that
alex jones is [ __ ] up right he really
[ __ ] up with the
um the sandy hook thing really [ __ ] up
he's had some mental health issues he's
had some
substance issues particularly with booze
and he also is constantly around
conspiracies and i think you get
legitimately psychotic
when you you delve down those roads i
think you lose your [ __ ] mind it's a
tough
and he lost his [ __ ] mind he lost his
[ __ ] mind on more than one occasion
he has but i mean he knows what
everybody
says is your mic on jamie i think your
mic's on it's very loud over there
he knows he's made mistakes he said on
the show that he wants to you know
correct his mistakes like
but the thing is he also um gives out a
lot of
real information i had three
yeah is there a third one in there what
did you get how did didn't get anything
you didn't get any i had nachos right
before i came in here what i thought
this was for you no it's for you
yeah fish for me thank you it's the
first time in my life i've ever passed
on mcdonald's for the record
outrageous you got a filet of fish three
of them they're great you're the only
person who gets the filet of fish
they're massively popular yeah
i've never seen anybody black people
love them they call them the mcfish
that's true it's not racist that's a
fact
i've heard a lot of black people kind of
have a mick fish it seems racist but i
don't think it is
it is it's right on the edge there's
something
on the edge that might be the last thing
on the menu i would get is a filet of
food
it's great they're very good they're so
good they steamed
so you're saying that if everything's
equal and trump wins
everything he won in 2016. right
he still has a very narrow path to
victory no so the point that i was
making and
i'll explain it for people who didn't
get the gist of it but it basically
if you take the polls in 2016 and do the
same sort of pro-trump swing that
happened on election day
they've done that and when you calculate
those numbers it's still biden with 335
electoral votes
so even if you have that same pro-trump
swing it's still biden winning by a
fairly safe margin
now to get to your point about does he
have a path yes trump has a path for
sure
but it's basically one path and he can't
afford any mess-ups along the way so he
has to win
he has to win florida he has to win
pennsylvania he has to win
arizona he has to win ohio and these
like
ohio and iowa are the only two swing
states where he's actually up in the
average of the polling
all the other ones he's down and there's
also another crazy thing going on which
and i struggle to believe this as well i
think trump is probably going to win
texas but the polling right there now is
they're actually dead tied
biden and trump are dead tied in texas
that is crazy
doesn't that skew uh bias towards
democrats because they're
traditionally um voting earlier by mail
yeah so that was another point that i
was going to get to when the votes roll
in
everybody's going to freak out at every
single thing that they see
but there are some states that count the
mail-ins first and when they count the
mail-ins first it's going to look like
biden's winning in a landslide
and then there's other states that do
the opposite which is they count the on
the day
votes first and the states that do that
it's going to look like trump is winning
in a landslide
so basically everybody has to relax
until you actually get
you know to a very high percentage of
the votes counted before you really know
what's going on
because there's going to be big swings
throughout the night in virtually every
state but i actually have the specific
states if you're interested in knowing
which states are going to swing like
that well let's find out where we're at
right now
is there anything jamie that shows us
where we're at right now here we go
look at that florida looks like trump
alabama trump mississippi trump it's
trump trump okay so here right now
trump is the president it's over he won
again so right now
this is blue because that's and again
okay that's because they're counting the
mail ins first and the mailings are
heavily bid and see that's what i'm
saying is like
it's a little misleading to watch it
second by second because it there it's
going to be skewed based on which votes
they're counting
do you see what i'm saying what's the
chance we don't have an answer
tonight 100 probably 50 or 60 percent
chance we don't have an answer what's
the chance that people handle that
maturely and don't burn things down and
throw bricks or win
negative 14 000 right
look so far it's 85 55 joe biden's
winning
so there's a few surprises up there by
the way they're obviously texas is a
surprise but even ohio
trump was up in ohio in the average of
polls and that's looking blue but again
i don't want to get ahead of myself
because i just told you guys don't pay
attention until the number gets up a lot
more
yeah 60 40. no see that's going to swing
back to trump though as time goes by
because
there's no way ohio is going to finish
on that number no way
not a chance in hell only 32 reporting
that means they're counting the mail-ins
that's what that tells me
and all the other states are just in in
play
um so as time goes by the polls close at
different times
and so i could tell you the order that
everything closes here we're supposed to
get
seven o'clock we had vermont virginia
georgia south carolina indiana and
kentucky georgia's the only one of those
that's really a swing state
um 730 we had we have north carolina
ohio and west virginia north carolina
and ohio are both swing states
then at eight o'clock we get clocked
over the head so we just got clocked
over the head here we have
washington dc delaware maryland
massachusetts rhode island connecticut
illinois new jersey
maine's first district new hampshire
pennsylvania florida
maine second district mississippi
missouri tennessee alabama oklahoma
only one two three of those are swing
states we really have pennsylvania
florida and maine second district and
then nine o'clock we get new york and a
bunch of others as well
i've never felt a time where the country
was more on
edge during an election because there's
never been a time where it's been this
bad no way ever
no way they came up with things they
said there's like a political
i forget what it is but there's some
indicator of political tension they said
it's higher now than the
i civil war i don't know about that one
people i mean that's shooting each other
in the face
well listen they're very polite and
genteel
that is true and they wore powdered ways
that could happen with us though
you know i think honestly joe i think
that we just have too many good
distractions to ever be in a civil war
like people might think like oh let's go
do it and then they go you know netflix
has some new [ __ ] out and i'd rather
just watch that
you know what i mean we can fight and
there will be there will be
civil unrest like we've been seeing but
you know
i don't think it would ever get to the
point of a real civil war so what
happened with that kyle written house
kid
like the judge didn't press charges but
then they extradited him
to uh kenosha right right
so what happened there i don't know i
watched the tape and you know clearly
they he went
to him and his parents went to the the
protest right with
heavily armed right which is not that's
a choice that the family makes right i
mean that's
that's a certain type of family that
goes heavily armed to a protest
um we didn't do that when i was growing
up um
and then there was a skirmish but if you
watch the video and people got mad at me
on twitter because i said that i think
if you watch the video you do see people
chasing him
uh and then he shoots them which again
this is all good he's in court now right
isn't he
bail for kyle something happened where
the judge said he wasn't going to
prosecute him that's why i was confused
i thought he was being released because
i had read
another ruling where the judge wasn't
going to press charges and a bunch of
youtube people are making these videos
about it
like kyle rittenhouse are going to free
him and then all sudden he's now
uh got two million dollars bail i saw on
twitter that somebody tweeted uh it said
it was a sign
that said kyle's life matters
oh jesus yeah and i thought that should
be about me
and not him it should be kyle dunnigan
keep up that uh
instagram page the the thing is like
he's not even supposed to be open
carrying so him carrying a gun was
illegal
it was not good what's that jamie
this is probably why you read from the
other day well that says his extra diet
to face homicide charges i feel like
listen the kids got horrible parents
they're probably there it's probably a
very bad family not that this excuses
the behavior
like i think the family drove him to the
protest right
jesus christ really i believe so yeah
it's like the mom and the dad i mean
this is not a good group
now there was something else jamie this
is not it there was something else where
the
they were not pressing charges i guess
somebody else did
yeah probably illinois was not pressing
charges so that wisconsin
could but it was in kenosha right the
actual shooting was in kenosha
wasn't it
yeah but he's from illinois i believe i
think that sounds right i think that's
what it was
so illinois wasn't going to charge him
but kenosha
he probably went home and yeah he had
been being held in illinois he went home
and got arrested they remember they
didn't arrest him right away
yeah they took a trip to the protest so
where he was not from the area they were
having which is even more weird
crazy so a lot of people are all about
this man a lot of people love this uh
you know tactical life yeah kind of
lifestyle where they're just kind of
searching for stuff to do
what do you attribute that to like the
rise and violence and the rise of people
kind of
video games is that it what do you think
it is no i'm not playing
i think um honestly man i and some
people might come after me for this but
i really believe that
over the years the evidence would show
that when people feel like
there's zero hope for a brighter future
and they're perpetually [ __ ] on by a
system that doesn't give a [ __ ] about
them
that yeah usually you turn to more
extreme
ideologies across the political spectrum
right it makes a lot of sense
i mean i wouldn't really think that
that's why he showed up at that protest
with a gun
no because i was just going to say you
have to look at everything on a
case-by-case basis and there are going
to be many
individual instances where somebody does
something [ __ ] up because of
say mental illness or somebody does
something [ __ ] up because they were
brainwashed into some sort of
fundamentalist cult from when they're a
kid
but i think the broader societal trends
where
these things kind of catch on and more
and more people are willing
to be involved in some sort of violence
i think you have to have an unhealthy
society in the first place
to have that flourish you see what i'm
saying yeah i do see what you're saying
yeah there's a that makes that makes
sense i mean listen
this is probably the classic example but
you couldn't have had hitler rise to
power
without the treaty of versailles which
[ __ ] germany after world war one
and so you had this whole generation of
germans who were like we've been [ __ ]
[ __ ] on and left behind and you know
what what are we
what are we supposed to do we feel like
there's no way out and then you have
this charismatic guy come up and say hey
it's not your fault
blame the jews no yeah it is them so
this is what happens i mean
and i really fear that stuff is going to
get worse in this country because
the economic situation is just abysmal i
mean
you talk about this all the time on your
show but when you shut down the economy
basically because of the virus you can't
shut down the economy
and then not give people a lifeline
monetarily because then they can't pay
the [ __ ] bills
this isn't rocket science you know in a
lot of other countries joe what they did
is
they did like this wage replacement
thing where they temporarily
nationalized wages so in other words if
the government told you
hey you can't work because of kovid they
would then say
and that's why we're going to pay 75 of
your wage until covet is over
could they have done that in this
country oh we absolutely could have done
it we chose not to do it in fact what we
did is probably the worst of
all worlds which is we took trillions of
dollars and threw them at the
corporations
and said here we're giving you a bailout
and then the corporations turned around
and fired people anyway
yeah in the beginning of cove with like
trump they would have like these press
conferences and they would be like
there would be like the ceo of buffalo
wild wings
let's bring out the ceo of buffalo wild
wings and the guy's like hey
we're just committed to helping we're
taking some of our napkins and making
face masks it was just this crazy group
of people that came out
like the guy who ran red lobster was
like we're also getting involved in the
fight
it was absurd it's always corporate like
always
it's always corporate it's like listen
let's let's let dave and busters make
ventilators
the idea that they would give those
people that money and not have a clause
in there where you can't fire people
is amazing that's right i mean and again
this also happened in the wall street
bailout
back you know under bush under obama
they always do the same thing
they bail them out and they have no
strings attached and then what happens
is
you know these executives paid bonuses
to the same people who crash the company
and you know there's no accountability
those people fail
up all the time they fail up oh i
bankrupted my company but it's okay
the gold the government gave me you know
billion dollars because goldman sachs
basically owns the government
you know and that's how it works and
it's incredibly corrupt and that's why
when something bad happens
and the people need a bailout they never
get a ballot what's what did people get
a one-time 1
200 stimulus check which is amazing and
we thought at least it was going to come
more frequently and never came again one
check in eight months
is kind of insane people don't have
money to to stay afloat there are people
that have been trying to get
unemployment for like
six months that's right they can't even
get unemployment because these [ __ ]
state i mean it's crazy
and all the protection for people
getting evicted is
soon gonna expire that's right and so
we're about to you know i saw a tweet
about this earlier from
the guy at the washington post one of
the only good people at the washington
post and he was basically listing it and
he's like
here are the things that expire you know
in the upcoming however many months
and people are screwed man they're
screwed i don't know how they're going
to pay bills we're already seeing polls
where like 30 percent of people say
i can't make rent so what could what
could i mean have those people tried
hustling and grinding
only fans is seeing a big explosion i
think garyvee
would would basically tell them that
they should just invest in themselves
keep going keep going just never give up
you just never give up and just hustle
and grind
hashtag hustle and just you know just do
it
um so what country handles it well so
the example that we've spoken about this
before but um i liked early on i liked
what
japan did because japan did like limited
shutdowns they did some shutdowns
because some things there's no escaping
it
it makes sense to shut them down just
because of the nature of what they are
like bars everybody's breathing on each
other two feet away or whatever
so he did limited shutdowns but
basically the only thing they did is
they had a universal mask policy
and culturally it's viewed like you're
the biggest [ __ ] on the planet if
you're not wearing a [ __ ] mask in a
place where you should be wearing a mask
and then they only had a thousand
coveted cases when we had like eighty
thousand ninety thousand hundred
thousand and rising steadily
so that's one way we could have done it
or the other way you could have done it
is you could have copied any of the
european nations that when they shut
down
they did hey we'll pay you seventy five
percent of your wages until this thing
is over
what you're you're france was one that
did that where they shut it down and
paid people i think it was 75
of their wages but i think the uk did
that too for a little bit it may have
been 80 of their wages but isn't this a
thing where
unfortunately a lot of those other you
know or
fortunately however you want to say a
lot of those other countries
they just are they're more of a monolith
and it's easier
you know those people are there's not
this idea of
you know the freedom and and uh doing
your own thing
and and and owning your own business
like a lot of those countries are
by their nature the populace is just
more submissive
there's definitely there's definitely
cultural differences
right but i think that especially in the
case of france
the government is scared of the people
because they're like you better [ __ ]
do [ __ ] that's gonna help us or else why
are you even in power
whereas here i feel like we're more like
okay just government don't [ __ ]
[ __ ] this up too much right you know
what i mean right so but again it
you there were multiple ways to address
this
and if you go the way japan went you
could have kept a lot more stuff open
and just had everybody wear masks
so if you want was anybody in government
calling for more
stimulus checks was anybody in
government call calling for more relief
was anybody in government calling for
like anybody on the left
calling for these checks oh absolutely i
mean
bernie sanders was calling for it the
squad who's always made fun of they were
calling for
they have to say right on this economic
stuff not only were people calling for a
show i believe
one of these things passed i think it's
called the heroes act and
there were provisions where they gave
people more of a recurring
stimulus check this wasn't a wage
replacement i should be clear we're not
talking about nationalizing wages like
they did over there
but you can do a similar version of that
by just doing a universal basic income
you know that's andrew yang's idea
that's something that he's really
popularized there's other ways to go
about it
recurring stimulus quarantine that nancy
bliss was giving a tour of her
like town or her house listen she's the
worst and she was showing the different
gelatos that she had in her freezer
this is right after 30 million people
were instantly made unemployed
and nancy pelosi was like get going we
like the chocolate
and then we like this and it was like
the craziest thing i've ever seen
and that's the party that's supposed to
care but she's okay she's done
so many things like that yeah so many
like she she lied about telling people
like when people were uh like
when the pandemic was first starting
she's telling people please go out go to
china
yeah people were acting like total
idiots and they weren't listening to the
real experts early on and everything was
incredibly politicized but to answer
your question though
from before trump and mnuchin were
calling for it too joe
they also wanted stimulus checks the
people who didn't want stimulus checks
nancy pelosi and mitch mcconnell but
trump and mnuchin the treasury secretary
wanted simulus checks because listen
trump knew hey you know i'm kind of
struggling
in the polls here i want to throw a hail
mary pass one of the ways to get people
to like you
you know three weeks before an election
cut him another stimulus check and he
famously wanted his name on the checks
he said put my name on the check so that
when people cash it they know that it's
for me and then they're more likely to
vote for me
and what got in his way was nancy pelosi
who
wouldn't accept any deal even if it was
a good deal and mitch mcconnell who even
if nancy pelosi accepted the stimulus
deal
mitch mcconnell would have blocked it
anyway so those are the real ghouls
because trump
wanted stimulus checks mnuchin wants to
stimulus to their credit do they ever
leave
she's 100 does she ever go away
i know she's spooky when she went to
that [ __ ] beauty salon and had no
mask on and then was talking about they
should apologize they set me up
like you know i've said this before i'll
say it again i don't even have hair
and i knew that beauty salons are closed
right everyone knew you know you that
lady's 150 years old she must get her
hair dyed every 15 minutes
the greatest story about her was there
was a bird that got in her george
downtown house and she had to chase this
big bird out of her
i mean she's just as real but the fact
that she went to a place that was shut
down
and she wasn't even wearing a mouth
right like all the like they're just
hypocrites
yeah they don't care yeah you need new
leadership
you know what's been amazing jimmy dore
jimmy dore's [ __ ] podcaster he is
he's a good friend of mine i love jimmy
dore he's calling
everybody out everybody in the left
right breathes
fire he breathes fire he doesn't be able
to
[ __ ] he goes hard he was doing this
thing on obama i forgot about this where
obama went to flint michigan and was
drinking the water
it was fake drake he's like could i get
a sip of water can i get a glass of
water
this is not a stunt i actually need a
glass of water i'm actually thirsty kids
are getting poisoned here as he's doing
this yeah like this
this is what he does
it took a little poison it's kind of a
fun bit though he says
this is not a stunt i mean hey
could i get a glass of water we still
don't have clean water in flint michigan
why is that so hard to fix i think the
reason why
they didn't want to spend the extra
money to get the proper
pipes and so then when it got terrible
and it was
contaminated they were like whoopsie and
then i don't know
how at this late date they haven't fixed
it yet that strikes me right that was
the obama administration so
happened under obama trump
administration it hasn't been repaired
obama didn't do anything serious trump
didn't do anything seriously that's
people's lives is it people's lives
long-term repercussions right so we're
talking about people now
who knows what it's like 15 years from
now 20 years now growing up
with that water and listen people
this is the stuff that actually matters
to people if you really
if you want to be successful running for
political office
it's not that difficult it's the bread
and butter issues it's the basics
wages jobs you know i don't want your
water to be poisoned
what stops them from fixing these things
a lot of it's corruption a lot of it's
the fact that these politicians take
money
from corporations and billionaires and
then they turn around
and they serve them and they don't do
anything that their constituents want
because as a general rule
whatever the people want is opposed by
the billionaire class the billionaire
class just wants
more tax cuts for themselves regular
people if you look at the polls they
want you know a living wage
for example they want to end the wars
they want to do an infrastructure deal
and give people jobs like the things are
very basic and actually this gets back
to what we were talking about earlier
because
trump in 2016 he was he never got credit
for running a superb campaign
because he really did when hillary
clinton was not stepping foot in the
rust belt to campaign
he was doing rallies there in the final
weeks leading up to the election
where he would non-stop hammer on jobs
and he would say you know
hillary and bill they outsourced your
job with nafta they outsource your job
with permanent normal trade relations
with china i'm going to bring your job
back
i'm the outsider she's the insider they
sent your kids to go die in a war i want
to get us out of the war
and he just kept hammering her and
hammering her and hammering her and the
reason he won is because those states
are the states that he picked off
to win the electoral college he won by
something from like 70 000 to 110 000
votes
and in fact i kind of want to show you
this ad because it it
shows it perfectly trump's closing ad in
2016 that's actually what it's called on
youtube
jamie if you want to pull that up uh
trump's closing argument ad or something
like that
the ad is phenomenal it's it's policy
based it's substance based and
he portrays himself as the outsider and
then comparing how good his campaign was
in 2016
versus how shitty it is this time around
i'm not surprised
that joe biden who barely has a
functioning brain
is casually up by nine points eight
points nine points whatever but
it's do you wouldn't you agree that it's
not that joe biden's run a good campaign
he said people hate trump that's exactly
right that's exactly right but
they didn't hate trump 2016. trump 2016
was a good politician
the best was a really good politician he
did in this cycle is not
really go out to deal with the public
hyde like every time he did he [ __ ] up
of the time exactly so that was if
there's anything that they did good at
keeping him away from the people
do you think though that if covet didn't
happen where the economy was before
trump was much more likely to win no he
was winning a hundred percent much more
likely to win
i mean trump is is i mean he's
he wins do you buy the argument
that trump is responsible for the
economy's
big boom or do you think that he was
riding
off the wave of obama or do you think
it's a combination of both things see
that's interesting because i actually
don't agree with either one of those
i think the economy was always a house
of cards i don't buy it when people say
oh we have a low unemployment rate and
the stock market is doing well so people
are doing well
no even before kovitz 78 of the country
was living paycheck to paycheck like
it's a house of cards they use these
indicators which are not good economic
indicators for regular people they're
good economic indicators for the top 10
that have [ __ ] stocks
you know what i mean right and and by
the way it's the gig economy right it's
not that people were necessarily
unemployed but people were underemployed
they would have these they'd have these
[ __ ] degrees from
colleges and then they'd have to go take
a job where they're basically making
minimum wage
at working as an independent contractor
not an employee so like
the economy was always a house of cards
and i never bought the argument and by
the way
not a hypocrite on this because when
obama was acting like his economy was
good i was like your economy's
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's got the same problem
as it was under trump
these are not good economic indicators i
care about wages
for example rates of unionization
usually go right along with the health
of the middle class back when we had
strong unions in this country we had one
of the healthiest middle classes in the
world what killed that up nafta
um no nafta was had a lot to do with the
outsourcing of jobs actually permanent
normal trade relations with china
was worse on that front there was more
outsourced under that than under nafta
um but we did lose a lot of jobs
in the auto industry we lost a job well
a lot of jobs that was because
again that was because of corruption
that's because the people who were the
executives at these companies
they pay the politicians to run their
campaigns
and then they would go to the
politicians and said hey hey i finance
your last campaign
i need you to do me a favor i want to
you know make my product a lot cheaper
so i'd like to ship it to some chinese
factory where we have
you know 14 year old working for me as
opposed to paying
an american worker a living wage with
good benefits
so it all comes down to money it all
comes down to you know
corruption and that really does show
what hypocrites we are because all these
people who are progressive they all have
iphones in their pockets
yes that's right and you're right we're
all hypocrites all of us are here
that like unless you're buying some
phone that
what like what is the most we've talked
about this before jamie but i don't
remember anything
what is the most ethical phone you can
buy
because it's clear is it the fair phone
remember right
i think i think i learned that from you
yeah that's right that's right that's
what it is
and uh even that like where are the
minerals coming from if you follow the
chain
and there's slaves somewhere and there's
a slave there's a slave somewhere
how do you what do you do with that i
know that's the problem it's we're all
complicit in these things what do you do
i mean i mean we could do what we can
control
and i did think you know a lot of
trump's rhetoric in 2016
on trade are they really slaves in the
china
that are making the [ __ ] slaves in the
chinese
this is beautiful it was actually an
expose recently written by a guy
who uh posed as a he's a guy of chinese
descent but i believe he's american and
he worked in
a factory uh making iphones
and doing one thing 12 hours a day and
he wrote a story about it like
how inhumane the conditions are there
and
you try to get it in people's heads like
this is what you're supporting when you
buy a phone
what's really kind of crazy is that
apple with all their money
right and they're my favorite phone
company right they're my favorite phone
company because they don't
they don't they don't sell your
information
like google does right yeah they care
about privacy even with your
uh with apple maps they don't they're
not like constantly collecting data
and then just selling it to all these
companies even them
they they don't see this massive
problem and they don't do anything about
it they just keep going down the same
road because it's been effective and
because
economically they have uh an obligation
to their shareholders and
this is the most profitable way to do it
so they keep doing it that way
that's right and this gets back to the
iraq and afghanistan war there's
trillions of dollars of mineral wealth
in afghanistan like a lot of the stuff
that ends up in your phone
yeah comes from there yeah for sure
lithium ion all that
stuff that's right a huge deposit of
lithium in afghanistan there's a big
story about that a few years ago
that they had found this uh new massive
deposit of lithium
i want you imagine this because and i
want to put this out there
if apple had their version of a fair
phone
like say this is our iphone 12 max pro
but this is our fair phone now this
phone is everybody
makes at least 15 dollars an hour right
this is this is a phone that doesn't use
any conflict minerals that
come from war-torn countries but it
costs a thousand dollars
but it's not as good as the phone that
costs
800 people who would get it right that's
the question i think a lot of people
would because they would virtually
signal they would say i'm using the fact
that that's not even like virtue signal
has a negative connotation
what what do you need like i have a new
phone i got a 12. i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
right i just like get 12 cameras
oh sides sides they're flat now
i love it um but i don't need it right
if you made a phone that's the
equivalent of the iphone 7
right and uh it costs 900 bucks but you
feel good about yourself you don't you
don't
feel bad what the [ __ ] do you need your
phone to do it's not making
complex computations it's not doing like
super difficult uh video rendering
unless you're a hardcore gamer on your
phone yeah what are you
really using your goddamn phone you're
facetiming your friends
you're making a few text messages you're
checking your email maybe you watch a
youtube video
you play a podcast when you're in your
car you listen to music what the [ __ ]
are you using your phone for
that you need a new processor ever you
oh the new oled has
you know the the new resolution is far
better than the old
there's more pixels listen i'm 53 years
old i need glasses to see my [ __ ]
text messages
i don't know what's going on with your
pixels if if you could
sell a phone that you you could feel
good about what you could say if a phone
company came out with that and that was
their big campaign
if it was ever a time now is the time
they could do that and i would buy it
yeah i don't [ __ ] need this stupid
new phone but i bought it because i'm a
[ __ ]
right but if a phone company came out
and said
this is it we have a phone maybe korea's
better maybe samsung's better
i don't know where they're making their
[ __ ] or where they're doing their [ __ ]
i think i think they're all bad i think
at the at the core of it so that's
slavery involved with all this
and it's terrible but it's probably true
right like is anybody's hands really
clean
and all this i mean it's relative right
like relatively clean cleaner i mean
but i mean this is why we need efficient
effective regulation
let's avoid the slavery thing well
listen it's harder
the the broader the scope the harder it
is so yes
if you're asking hey is it really
possible to know where we get
everything from for phones that are sold
here when none of the materials come
from here no it's really not possible
someone's gotta know right apple the new
phone has a bunch of recycled material
in it
sure but that means recycled from from
slaves
getting it on the ground from well from
other phones is what they're saying
but it originally came from slaves
getting those materials out of the
ground
i don't i'm just but not at that context
he's just saying it's not continuing to
feed the slavery pipeline
slightly better so apple's rare earth
recycling a new iphone series steps up
environmental response
yeah but that's just the environment
this is even though this is good because
they're not wasting the materials and
they're recycling the materials that's
good for the
environment right but that doesn't
address the foxconn workers who
live in a place where they have
dormitories and they have nets around
the building because so many people
jumped off
they decided to put nets up you would
need the international community to get
together and we all say to each other
all right no slavery yeah no slavery
and then some i mean some country would
decide we're going to be [ __ ]
because we'll get a competitive
advantage if we have slaves
and then they probably do it you know
what i mean but yeah it's well jimmy
pull up that fair phone
would you really get a fair phone no i'm
just
i wouldn't lie on the podcast it depends
how shitty it is though right
it's actually okay it's even less like
slightly less
uh i'm going to go slavery here it is
but
but can i air drop with the fair phone
it goes later
android so i mean oh so designed to last
what does it say
recycled and uh recycled
and fair materials 48 megapixel camera
that's pretty good you look like a punk
if you have this how dare you you look
like a punk if you pull out a fair phone
look at this [ __ ] guy he doesn't even
agree with slavery
oh i have a fair phone oh you think
you've stopped slavery because you have
one fair phone well let's look
why do they have no text you're actually
making a great point
you're making a great point always doing
that because like it's not an individual
issue it's like when people say about
clients never know when i'm doing it
it's like when people say about climate
change like oh did you drive a [ __ ]
car is that what you did you drove a car
to get here did you know that [ __ ]
climate change has happened
it's like yeah [ __ ] and it's not like
one individual can really make that much
of a difference
you actually need action from a higher
level like 73 percent of the emissions
that lead to climate change
come from the same come from i'm sorry
outside of europe what does it say there
companies they only still have like 100
percent or 90
of the emissions some crazy stats that
i'm not remembering in the eea
in switzerland as an organization based
in amsterdam the netherlands we
currently focus our sales
efforts in europe at the same time we
are researching the market
and logistic possibilities to sell
outside of europe
you can find our full list of countries
where we sell and ship to
okay when they try to sell outside of do
they sell it to america can i buy one
does it say united states lmnop qrs
nope vatican city they don't even
yeah well when you're molesting children
you really want a fair phone
they don't even allow it here no they
don't sell it here
i think we call we say this is slavery
but we don't really know
right well at the heart of it no with
the mines yet there's
there's child slaves in those mines
shipping outside of europe we do not
sell or ship
fair phone products outside of europe at
the moment yet
the good news is we plan to start
developing a selection of countries
outside but the question at the moment
is how fast can we make this happen is
amsterdam-based
organization we wanted to launch a fair
phone products in europe
yeah yeah for the coming time we will
continue to focus our sales efforts on
this region oh they don't have any plans
so that you can't even buy this [ __ ]
phone here but it's not a bad phone if
you look at what it is it's a 46
megapixel camera
uses android 10 which is i think that's
the latest
now is android 11 now i think they have
android 11 though
but tim is right this is not an
individual issue it has like action
needs to be taken at a higher level yeah
you can't just have one person right
that's your fair phone it's going to be
systemic
yeah well i got to be able to air drop
too and the point i was trying to make
which i couldn't get out of own system
works well
what phone says the the one we get when
we get the nice phone joey he's saying
he's pro slavery this is what he's doing
i'm not sprawling slavery but if you're
a child in china you have to keep
yourself occupied
you could upgrade your camera camera
modules kind of cool
that's pretty cool if it works good
discover the greener way to get new
features
wow so they have a module that you can
take out and then put back it probably
also means no water resistance with all
this modular [ __ ]
you're pulling out batteries and stuff
that means usually generally that you're
you're not going to be able to have uh
water resistance you seem like you're
actually somewhat interested in this joe
i am somewhat interested in this because
i recognize my own hypocrisy
by not supporting slavery but supporting
slavery
and it's also it's also weird to me that
in my opinion if i
am if i'm thinking about a progressive
tech company apple's at the top of that
list
they have the most elegant design they
have these like super intelligent people
working they have this beautiful campus
they have all these things they have an
enormous amount of money i mean apple
has more money than the united states of
america right they have more reserve
more cash reserves than anything like
there's how much what is
apple's cash reserve i think it's in the
trillions of dollars they have an
enormous amount of money
well they're incredibly successful but
here's the thing
that well i'm not saying it's not a lot
but it's about 200
billion dollars i thought it was in the
trillions that's how much they're
worth i believe i don't think they have
that in cash okay so in the
in cash they have hundreds of billions
of dollars
you can't use that you guys can't figure
it out you can't
pay slaves better money you can't say
they only have to work eight hours a day
it's about the supply chain how much
more would it cost
you know what i'm saying i hear you but
i think it's more about the supply chain
where like
at some point down the line they're just
getting something
from somebody else who's doing the work
elsewhere you know what i mean
like they come to them for the raw
materials for whatever it is and then
they put it together
owns the land where the minerals are
being extracted from and that person's
running a slave operation
pretty much this is why this is what the
cia would do it's like when we needed
minerals to whoever was running that
country they'd be like he seems like uh
he's hurting his own people yes he's a
genocide that's right
he must do there's always an argument
there's always something
right yeah always like that bill hicks
joke where they go uh
he's a hitler and whatever you need
folks
yeah well that's uh smedley butler right
that's what he's rightly butler
yeah where's your racket that is that's
really the extent of his argument or his
article rather is when he wrote that he
thought when he first enlisted into the
army
and by the way i believe that's 33. what
year was that
smedley butler war is a racket i want to
say it's 19 it's in the 1930s
and he wrote this 35 35 eerily
accurate account of what we're dealing
with today
when it comes to why we really take
military action on certain countries
and they really in his his case back
then he was talking about protecting
bankers and
yeah we had um soldiers who were
dishonorably discharged when they blew
the whistle on some of our allies having
child sex slaves
crazy well say that again we had
soldiers who were dishonorably
discharged when they blew the whistle
on our allies in afghanistan having
child sex slaves
so they spoke up and said our allies are
[ __ ] children here
and they were dishonest honorably
discharged but nobody likes a right but
no one wants a rat
good point that's a great point because
we also do horrible things and you're
like well if he's gonna rat out our
allies
they might rat out us yeah and they
probably [ __ ] kids too
yeah who who were these guys and where's
going on an article i read like five
years ago i'll try to you know
afghanistan they have this whole thing
where it's like they have ladyboys and
then they have like goat herders have
sex with the warriors
like like it's like a warlord culture
that's the extent of what i know about
it but
i wrote an article how you said that
knowing that you have like this
shallow about a very small amount of
information but it's very visual like i
know they're warlords and they're
working
on rocks there you go here it is u.s
soldiers told to ignore
sexual abuse of boys by afghan allies
yeah
also cross off afghan allies and right
u.s senators yeah
you know what i mean it's like that's
also the thing what's his name he was
this wasn't in one of the speakers
speakers of the house right
danny hastert hastert yeah well he was
molesting boys when he was working as a
wrestling coach
yeah and really good friends with tony
podesta john podesta
by the way if i want to say i think he
got
15 months you got an incredibly short
you're connected
when you're connected yeah yeah hastert
pull that up speaker the house
hastert and what he got and so
i mean that [ __ ] that is the tip of
some iceberg
somewhere absolutely i mean you you know
you've gone deeper
yeah so 15 months
15 months for [ __ ] kids imagine jesus
christ imagine think about
all these guys that are in jail right
now for pot non-violent drug
non-violent drug dealers a bunch of
dudes that
how about kamala harris what what what
how many did she put away
how many months she put away for way way
longer than 13 months
oh well you gotta cut off a good
behavior didn't [ __ ] the kids by the
way two months and they
this was one of the issues this was one
of the issues where trump could have hit
biden hard because biden did the crime
bill yeah and trump did the first step
act
yeah that's a reversal of the roles
there where you have like biden's acting
like the republicans and trump's acting
like the democrats it was tough to hit
kamal on that because trump was like
she put black people in jail the crowd's
like yes
no no no hold on and she's like
you know so it's a tough you gotta
really listen that's why yes
that's why he's had a hard time defining
biden because
you know if you hit him on the crime
bill that's like saying he's too tough
on crime but he did hit him on the crime
bill in that debate
i know but then in the next sentence
what did he do he said he won't even say
law and order this guy's okay with the
riots
you got to pick one you can't say he's
too tough on crime with the crime bill
and he's too soft on crime because he
won't say
crime bill wasn't just tough on crime
right he was tough on non-violent crime
which shouldn't be crime and it was it
was also like
it didn't give anybody a path for
redemption it just basically locked
people up
and then when you're dealing with this
is also during the time of the rise of
the private prison industry
and so all that is being funneled into
people's pockets right biden has always
been a shady guy right didn't he like
help all the credit card companies
reload yeah
yes in the bankruptcy bill the
bankruptcy bill
you can't file for bankruptcy on your
student loans all other forms of
debt you can file for bankruptcy on you
can't do it on student loans and now
this guy's
you know might be our next president
we'll find out dark is that you can't
file for bankruptcy on student loans no
matter what it is
you owe it forever there's people right
now that are getting social security
and they get some of their money docked
because they owe student loans
imagine you hit the end of the line
right you're 70 years old
you're tired every day your feet hurt
and your social security
check gets sliced because you have
student loans
that you never used anyway like
that education didn't do a damn good
not no good at all and the money the
reason why it was so expensive for that
education was the government was
subsidizing it that's right and there
are other
other developed countries a bunch of
them do basically they treat college the
same way we treat like high school here
where you could just go
you know i that is one of the reasons
why i supported bernie sanders
one of the reasons i supported him for a
couple reasons one the idea of
uh abolishing student debt two making
college free we want people to be more
educated
we want them to be more educated it's
one of the best ways to ensure that we
have i always say this what's the best
way to make america great have less
losers
what's the best way to have less losers
give more people opportunity
so get them out of debt for [ __ ] that
they did when they were 17
they didn't even know it they didn't
understand what they were doing you're
getting in debt for hundreds of
thousands of dollars for an education
that'd be
literally worthless like jamie went to
school for [ __ ] that doesn't even work
anymore
right you spent you make this education
or you get this education for like
computer programming
right or or you know you're learning
software that's
completely irrelevant by the time you
get out of school i mean
and you're hundreds of thousands of
dollars in debt you should be able to
sue
you should really you [ __ ] you made
me lose you should watch the sleep clean
get rid of the student loan debt i mean
we think about it we bail out yes
bankers we without wall street we have
endless amounts of money for the war
right for the war if we're gonna bail
out anybody it should be students
like jesus christ student debt medical
debt wow and by the way i like the
questions you asked kanye
because it was funny to me watching you
were you were very policy
focused you were like okay so what do
you think about the issue of student
loan debt like do you have a plan for
that
the big one for me was what are you
gonna do with the military
like if you have to if you have military
he said a prayer i believe was his
answer to that one
he's gonna consult jesus i like kanye a
lot and i thought that that was really
interesting that his
his answer for the military was not
something that he just ranted on
that was something they thought about he
said i would consult experts you know
yeah i'm a civilian
you know trump said that a lot too in
2016 when he was asked a question he
wasn't sure about he's like i'd be
surrounded by the best people
he never said it like the way kanye did
it and i'm not i'm not saying kanye west
should be president
but i i was genuinely impressed with his
thoughtfulness
mm-hmm genuinely you know i don't think
he should be president but by the way he
could be
what are the numbers not now he's not
winning this election
not this one but understand he could no
[ __ ]
like this is how [ __ ] sideways work
we've gone through the loop yeah
look if it was trump politician though
joe i really think trump was
a really he didn't get his due either
because the media hates him so much
that they didn't recognize what he was
doing was he wasn't
running like a traditional republican
which is like mitt romney style which is
uninspiring
he was running like a populist and that
appealed to people who otherwise would
there are two times obama voters who
voted for trump
yeah and guess what now they abandoned
him because he stopped
he didn't govern like we thought he
might when he was being a popular do you
think that was because he was lying when
he was running or do you think it's
because
the things that he was promising once
you get into office and you see the
reality of the job
no i'll explain it it's it's i think
trump is a path of least resistance guy
so when he got in power he surrounded
himself with the same
[ __ ] ghouls that have been destroying
washington all along
i mean he had gary cohn goldman sachs
steve mnuchin
goldman sachs larry kudlow from cnbc the
guy's never been right about anything
economically in his entire life but now
he's making decisions for the economy
and we can go down was john bolton on
foreign policy one of the same guys is a
[ __ ] war criminal who sent us to iraq
so trump spoke against the iraq war and
then he hired the guy who was most
responsible for getting us into [ __ ]
iraq
try to make sense of that one so the
problem is he picked all these
career insider swamp creatures and then
all of them were talking in his ear all
day every day
no no you can't do that thing you can't
stop the outsourcing no you can't get us
out of the wars you can't do this you
can't do that
and trump listen at the end of the day
all he really cares about is getting the
adulation
and he loves like when he's doing a
rally and the crowd is like
loving him that's his thing man that's
what he's into so he wants that love and
adoration
while he just keeps the status quo going
and holding it together with [ __ ]
band-aids and bubble gum you know like
that's what it is it's i'm gonna keep
the status quo going relatively normal
as i
portray myself i think you're right
about all of that but
there's got to be some allowance made
for the fact that like
he spent two years defending himself
from the
accusation that he was a russian spy
that's right
the democrats are here you know idea
that the guy was a russian
and that's the reason the democrats did
that is because
they don't have anything policy wise
that they're pushing
to make counter arguments right so
instead of saying like
what we're going to do is we're going to
abolish student loan debt and we're
going to you know fight with the
republicans on the stay out day in and
day out
they didn't do that they did exactly
what you said which is oh my god maybe
he's vladimir putin's puppet manchurian
candidate
not even in for america and of course
where'd that get us
absolutely nowhere by the way i love how
the mueller report got trump on
dick when it came to that and they the
democrats just acted like
they there was no day of reckoning was
like damn we really [ __ ] this up from
the beginning
i remember the one of the first or
second time i was on your podcast i told
you
that they're going to get nothing on the
russia thing yeah and they got nothing
on the russian thing
there's other kinds of standard issue
corruption going on people that claim
that the russia thing did show collusion
okay then why is trump still president
why he's one of them why hasn't anybody
around him
he's a prisoner jamie thinks that jamie
thinks that he was in the community
but he also pretended to have covet so
this is because he was scared of meeting
kanye
exactly so this is a pattern of behavior
did you get any hot results is there
anything yeah there's uh some [ __ ] going
down in florida
uh they've projected wins for both of
them it's going back and forth oh god
can i show you the trouble 2016. i sent
it to jamie yeah let's we're going to
look okay
oh this is 2016 okay okay yeah i dm'd it
to jamie i want to show you
how good he was that's it correct how
good he was
joe here we go
our movement is about replacing
a failed and corrupt political
establishment with a new government
controlled
by you the american people
the establishment has trillions of
dollars at stake
in this election for those who control
the levers of power in washington
and for the global special interest they
partner with these people
that don't have your good in mind
the political establishment that is
trying to stop us
is the same group responsible for our
disastrous trade deals massive illegal
immigration
and economic and foreign policies that
have bled
our country dry the political
establishment
has brought about the destruction of our
factories
and our jobs as they flee to mexico
china and other countries all around the
world
it's a global power structure that is
responsible for the economic decisions
that have robbed our working class
stripped our country of its wealth
and put that money into the pockets of a
handful of large corporations
and political entities the only thing
that can stop this corrupt machine is
you
the only force strong enough to save our
country
is us the only people brave enough to
vote out this corrupt establishment
is you the american people i'm doing
this
for the people and for the movement
and we will take back this country for
you and we will make america great again
okay great listen pretty goddamn good
that is not
like other republicans that's him being
incredibly populist right
and now i just want to show you because
i'll show you his 2020 closing ad
okay so you could compare okay jamie i
dm that to you as well it's the trump
tweet that says vote vote vote
this is what he released today as
basically his closing ad and
just look at how different this is okay
slow down hold on
he gave me a lead in like i was already
ready sorry about that yeah i get
excited sometimes
but that was a good ad right that's a
damn good great [ __ ] maybe you want
to take a time and she can go back and
vote for him
i mean it's a great ad no this starts
off with that how is joe jorgensen doing
i don't know point six percent
phenomenal
she's got point six percent yeah oh my
gosh this is bad
the dancing i don't know for a lot to
play that okay then mute it mute it but
keep it going because
the whole this is the this is the whole
second thing joe rogan he's just dancing
is this the song play the whole time i
dance i actually don't remember how long
it plays women i also got to be honest i
also like this one
everywhere i'm also equally assumed by
this
that's the macho man song isn't it isn't
it village people yeah why
yeah is it ymca yeah but what he's doing
is he's giving him all that stuff about
nafta a little bit for a second
why is that is that muted i don't want
to get this that is
yeah immediately that is his ad this is
the edge
ymca yes every other song he was playing
they got
dm's like they told him to stop playing
it they got cease and desist
but he's showing he's young he's vital
he just got done with covid he's
dancing here's the thing joe like he he
just had an amazing
person his attacks against biden don't
resonate as much as his attacks against
with hillary resonated what is it his
legs are broken it's stuck to the ground
he's like paralyzed what a weird dance
i'm gonna start doing that it's like a
guy that was in a car accident he's got
a loop he just got the same dancer this
is a crazy ad
but so it's just music he made a tick
tock video is what he did
so yeah it's a three minute ticket but
it's just music and him dancing that's
right
that is so bizarre okay so now beyond
this joe
because the main argument he's using
against joe biden is joe biden is some
sort of radical socialist antifa lover
and that's not landing but look at this
[ __ ] this ad is so dumb
look at his head who someone hates him
someone inside the white house hates him
and they made this ad they're like i'm
gonna sync his [ __ ] battleship with
this [ __ ]
i think i think you're both [ __ ] on
it but i think it it's it
he hit him get out and vote
it's ridiculous do you think he knows
it's over sure
maybe he doesn't even want to win who
knows maybe secretly
this is the craziest thing i've ever
it's the dumbest ad i've ever seen
that this move is so strange
he tweeted that with let's get some
updates
27 million views on that 27 million well
27 million people going what the [ __ ]
is this we're gonna get some um
uh we're gonna get some updates all
right let's see see where we're at we go
with fox
i say it's all red now it's just updated
as of
right now trump is up the biggest one i
think that i've seen so far is florida's
reporting at 89 percent
and trump is leading trump is leading so
trump needs that state to have any
chance and it looks like he's in the
lead by two percent which is actually
not terrible at 89
in which is actually looks like it's
solid for him at the moment okay so he's
going to win
well not necessarily and wait until they
call it but
he i mean this could i think it's i
think i think here fox's news
okay what so if he wins florida
what else does he do to wow look at that
he's just getting ohio or pennsylvania
he's in
no no no no no no okay he needs if he
wins florida
the next thing you have to look at is
pennsylvania and he must win
pennsylvania as well
how's pennsylvania looking
pennsylvania's leading blue at the
moment
seven percent reporting right and that's
all the mailings the mailings are 76
biden which is what i told you earlier
that the marylands are going to be
pro-biden and on the day votes are going
to be pro-trump
but he needs pennsylvania he needs
florida he needs
ohio so pennsylvania the polls are still
open
um pennsylvania yeah
well it says open hold on i'll tell you
one second it's uh
10 p.m there pennsylvania right
oh 9 p.m there are we haven't it says
open but it says close at 8 pm eastern
time so they should have closed about an
hour ago
okay so they have to count yes
pennsylvania closed at eight but they're
counting and they're starting again with
the mail-in votes which is why biden has
such a strong lead at the moment
but in the polling in pennsylvania biden
was up about five or six points in the
average of the polling so that's
basically trump's biggest hurdle
to winning the election is pennsylvania
because he's down five or six points
there
so if he can win florida which it looks
good for him
now in florida trump then it comes down
to pennsylvania
and if he can win pennsylvania then
you're getting now you're really having
a conversation about the election well
that's why
right that's what i said but no no but i
thought you were saying i thought you
were saying that was it and he wins
i'm saying that was it now we could play
the end again then he's in the ball game
if he wins florida and he wins
pennsylvania what else does he have to
do to win ohio
he's got to win ohio what does joe biden
have to do to win at this point
joe bi if joe bide first of all texas
looks blue right now i'm not saying it's
going to stay like that
if joe biden wins texas it's game set
match it's over
if joe if joe biden somehow comes back
in florida now he wins it's over games
gameplay
like there was a big push turned texas
blue that was like a big thing yeah
fascinating no this really is
fascinating because i
i think texas is going to go red but i
thought florida was going to go blue
so we'll see so this google is showing
it in a different in a way that's a
little more easier to look at
okay it shows all the groups of the
swings by the way scroll down scroll
down jamie for one second
north carolina is an important swing
state and right now biden is up just a
little bit there that and by the way
biden up in
ohio as well even though there's
probably early votes in just mail-in
but that's big too because trump needs
ohio and he needs pennsylvania
what's interesting too is the numbers of
people voting it seems like way more
people are voting
huge turnout joe huge turnout
what's the number i'll pull them up for
you right now it's 102
early whoa i didn't vote because i
thought too many people
isn't the early vote more than all of
the vote from
no it was some years yes that's what i
was going to say in for a texas specific
let him answer since he's the [ __ ]
expert you're looking at me jamie's like
no
no no yes texas
passed the total number of votes in
their pre-voting
in their mail-in votes they passed they
surpassed their
2016 total in just the mainland that's
insane that is where did you vote new
york
i didn't vote oh you didn't vote not wow
wow i can't believe you're surprised by
that well i know you weren't going to
vote for biden but i didn't know you
were not going to vote period
why is that what was i going to do vote
for trump no no no
go joe jorgensen or do uh i didn't vote
because
it looked kind of it looked gross the
voting because they were doing it in
fire play and firehouses and
libraries it was a little grotesque and
they all stand outside with a mask it
seemed very low red i went to dinner
instead
and that's how i've been doing it for
years i think so good
healthy so let me explain why i did what
i did so
basically for me it came down to
obviously i'm not going to support trump
i've ripped him a million ways to sunday
and i'll continue to do that i think
he's been
effectively governed as an establishment
republican with tax cuts for the wealthy
and continuing the wars and i to me
that's
you're done i have no interest in more
tax cuts for the rich i have no interest
in continued wars
i have no interest in deregulation and
stuff like that for biden
like my political awakening came with
the iraq war in 2003
when we basically were lied into a war
and we continued that illegal war
and um he was one of the guys who voted
for it and listen i truly believe that
everybody who voted for that iraq war
should be in prison i think they're all
war criminals
it was an illegal war uh even according
to the u.n
and over 200 000 innocent civilians are
dead
so basically i couldn't bring myself to
do it because
that was the most foundational
thing that happened when i was growing
up getting involved in politics and i
just can't look past that that's not a
little thing to me
so now if you want me to give you my
breakdown of the candidates do
i think overall joe biden is a lesser
evil
i do because joe biden's going to get us
back in the iran deal joe biden is going
to get us back in the paris climate
agreement
and those things i think are really
important um but i just couldn't
bring myself to pull over especially
because i live in new york and new
york's a safe state anyway it's not like
my
it's like my vote matters but i just
couldn't bring myself to do it man
just couldn't do it do you take heat for
that
um i didn't disclose what i was going to
do yet until right now
and so now you disclosed that you
weren't gonna vote for biden people were
already giving you heat for that
yeah well i said that right after the
primary when the feelings were raw with
bernie getting screwed again
so that's why i said it then you just
take that land down listen
is it he's is he that nice of a guy he
really likes joe biden number one
number two i think he really buys into
the lesser evil framework where he
thinks
i want to go with the guy who's you know
better on more of the things that i
agree like for example
biden has signed up for doing bernie
sanders living wage idea 15
minimum wage and so you know bernie
takes that and he goes okay this is
enough for me to go out there and
push you and make an argument for you
now will biden actually do that i don't
know
i hope he will i have no idea if he
actually will okay what are the
arguments against that
well people say oh it's going to lead to
an increase in unemployment because
small businesses can't afford
to you know pay for especially at a time
like right now with covid
where small businesses are having a hard
time staying open either way
but well also there's also arguments
that these are jobs for young people
that perhaps still work at home
the data doesn't bear that out though
there's plenty of people who work full
time and they make them you know
but you don't want people that are
making the filet of fish complacent
like you want them working well they
need to listen they need to know there
were steaks whitney cummings just texted
me she's like i can't believe you guys
are eating fish it's like
shut up she yelled at me for not voting
she yelled at me for not voting she said
it's
not bad for my tell her i said tell her
i said thank you because she's backing
up my filet of fish argument
she said it will be bad for my career if
i don't vote she goes you should do you
want to be the person in 2020 who didn't
vote and i said yes
i mean listen it's it is what it is you
oh you live in california right i live
in california
it's not a swing are you registered to
vote there or not i don't know
my business manager called me should we
register you to vote i said
try to get my license back i got a
suspended license in new york
they're trying to put me in jail let's
focus on that and then we'll get to
voting we'll get the voting in three or
four months
you know uh tim used to sell sub-prime
mortgages yes okay
correct correct so and i and mike's part
of the project am i living
he was poked out of his mind and by a
by a an authoritarian government who
took me and a lot of men from long
island who were trying to help people
realize the american dream
were unfairly painted as criminals
just because we were expanding up
people's uh ability to get credit
sorry sorry i wanted everyone to have a
pool
yeah so people want to give that
perspective i'm glad you said and i'm
here to give it you started out selling
subprime mortgages
i started out selling cars oh wow and i
as well was also
on many substances oh that's so fast i
was doing it
that stuff were you good what kind of
cars were you selling um i was selling
chevy's
and are you were you like a good
salesman or no hiker
i'm too nice and i don't give a [ __ ] if
the person buys the car or not i mean i
feel like you pay yeah
but like drugs i'm too honest what i was
going to say is i was probably the
number one
um consumer of four loco back when it
was the original
okay well you know
well if i had that i probably would have
done the same thing but for loco was
taken off the shelves because people
were having [ __ ]
time we were doing lines of blow off a
desk and then taking people's 1040s but
white out getting them
getting deals done uh jamie's just
motioned to me to get you guys trying to
try to not talk over each other oh [ __ ]
i apologize
kyle's moving into your camera oh oh i
keep doing that i'm sorry let me scoot
this
way more you have i've been doing that
the whole thing you need to learn sign
language both of us do it i know to
spell it but it takes too long
dude the sign language interpreters are
so out of control now i remember those
things
actually a fake one next to obama it was
hilarious he had no idea what he was
doing he was just doing a bunch of tick
tock moves
and the guy got three inches away from
obama that's insane
it shows you how [ __ ] poor
poorly managed a lot of those situations
are where
like such poor security right poor
planning you have a [ __ ] guy you
don't even know
the president of the united states i
want to know how long he was doing that
too
before people it was a while actually
signed are like hey hey hey
what is that right what is this crazy by
the way
that's a good that shows how important
confidence is because the person started
doing it just really confidently like
they belong there yeah and that was
enough for everybody to be like i guess
all the people now it's disgusting what
they do they're very big and everything
and it's like we get it
but you're distracting because most
people can hear so what you're doing is
you're distracting
for me i'm trying to listen the message
it's very distracting to have somebody
who's very like over the top doing it
and that's true i get it i get it deaf
people for the most part are very rude
there was a
ruling uh today about gavin newsom
there's a ruling about garen
gavin newsom that is uh no like
something about his uh
using unconstitutional policies
yeah he's you know he he's a
unliked man right now in california well
talking of car salesman he looks like
the sleaziest car salesman on the planet
well he looks like a guy who should be
president
like he looks like in a movie yeah in a
movie maybe he looks like a pretty looks
like a president he sounds like a
president
he's a good looking dude judge rules to
limit california governor's power
powers admit pandemic and he's out of
[ __ ] control out of his mind
it's amazing how much money people are
losing too like
disneyland disneyland is losing some
insane number of
millions of dollars a day
the order prevents gavin newsom from
exercising any power under california
emergency services act which amends
alters or changes
existing statutory law or makes new
statutory law or legislative policy
the judge determined that the california
emergency services act itself
was constitutional but noted that it
does not permit the governor
to amend statutes or make new statutes
that's what i've been saying the whole
time he's like this guy is an autocrat
the government does not have the power
or authority to assume the legislators
role
of creating legislative policy and
enactments
it's just so spooky how people get into
power and you find out how much they
love using it go back to that again it
says
uh determining one of his orders was an
unconstitutional exercise of legislative
power
yeah gross it's scary there man
like like they're they're giving you
orders on what you can do for
thanksgiving
like yeah you're crazy you can't have
more than three families you can't have
any singing you can't uh wait a minute
you have to be outside
is that true yeah yeah yeah no singing
singing no singing you have to be
outside it has to only go on for two
hours
as if after two hours everyone turns
into a pumpkin this is absurd
and this is a abuse of power and he must
be
they gotta they gotta stop this they
they do have to stop but it just the
type of person
that would say that imagine being a
governor you're dealing with half your
[ __ ] states on fire like everyone's
out of work and you're like you can't
sing
don't sing that's absurd and your
parties you you have to wait
is this real they can't sing yes yes
yes yes i saw this going around too and
i didn't think it was real when i saw it
didn't look into it i'm looking into it
now look into it now that doesn't sound
real
there was something put out but i'm our
favorite website snope says this is
false
yeah that's like that's that's like
facebook meme or some [ __ ] joe no
no don't say that unless you're sure
jamie's wrong all the time with this
stuff because he only googles these
lefty
liberal fake news sites snopes snopes is
a fake news site they get busted all the
time for fake news
very biased by the way the guy who runs
snopes like
he's a huge democrat like the the whole
the whole organization is heavily
left-leaning but wait that but that
didn't set the alarms off to you the oh
you can't sing
what [ __ ] government agency would do
that telling you you can't sing
that's next i think maybe six months ago
that might have been funny but now it's
like
now you're like okay i'm sure that's
gonna be next yeah um i'm telling you it
was on fox news yeah no no no no no no
no
well fox news is certainly i'm always
saying it wasn't being passed around but
i was saying that it was being passed
around
under false pretenses on fox news it
says no more than three households
present
parties no longer than two hours guests
must stay outside avoid singing
chanting and shouting right yeah but
again that's where is that coming that's
fox news
health it's a quote from the california
department just google it you [ __ ]
and don't interrupt kyle anymore
him that time i said that sounded fake
you got to look that up i mean
circulating on facebook says this is not
accurate [ __ ] snopes okay celebrities
rip california governor's new uh what
it's got to be yeah that they could
viruses california gavin newsom's
thanksgiving rules
click on that that's daily mail though i
know this is not something
if they are saying what i want to hear
do not understand how this works
this is like an experiment in you know
ideological
confirmation bias what i want to hear
the guidelines but this is there must be
a link the aux server that's over
yeah there's there never is a link
because they're muslim with these listen
chuck woolery and he's backing us
up you're moving too fast there's all
these dumb pop-ups we'll be right back
in two and two
the order requires a host of pri okay
uh announced ahead of uh thanksgiving
holiday defined gatherings of social
situations
bring people together from different
households at the same time in a single
space or place the order requires that a
host of private gatherings to limit
attendant
stop you're moving i'm trying to find a
link but you're ignoring
while i'm reading you know that right
well here's the link that would tell us
okay
or not let's go california department of
public health summary
this provides an updated plan for
california to gather
outside their household and replaces
the prior gatherings guidelines issued
on september 12th
scroll up again mandatory requirements
for all gatherings scroll
it's frozen alone oh of course it's
frozen
it's goddamn california website piece of
[ __ ]
how do they get rid of chanting when
when when california everyone's a
satanist
and they need that occult chant that's a
good question
not consider it how funny is that that
the website crashes crashed the website
well we're live oh my god
that's right we're live whoa that's
crazy i forgot we're live
that's [ __ ] crazy here we go okay
here we go mandatory
requirements for gathering attendance
gatherings must include
uh gatherings that include more than
three households are prohibited
okay this is this is exactly what it
said snopes he [ __ ]
stop stop scrolling keep the households
that you interact with stable
it was their singing singing things i'm
curious about it by spending time with
the same people risk of transmission is
reduced
okay gather outdoors gatherings that
occur outdoors are significantly safer
than anywhere together all gatherings
must be held outside again that's what
the thing said attendees may get may go
inside to use the restroom
as long as restrooms are frequently
sanitized they're telling you
you have to sanitize your [ __ ]
restaurant restroom if you want to go
inside
gatherings may occur in outdoor spaces
that are covered by umbrellas canopies
awnings roofs and other shade structures
that provide at least three
sides of this space or 75 open to the
outdoors
this is [ __ ] outrageous okay uh
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh the crovid part is
um i mean gatherings of no more than
three households is permitted
in a public park or outdoor space
if unrelated gatherings of other groups
up to three households also occurring in
the same park
or outdoor space uh if multiple such
gatherings are occurring
mixing between the groups group
gatherings is not allowed
you can't mix with other people that you
see at the park additionally multiple
gatherings of three households cannot
joint cannot be jointly organized or
coordinated to occur
in the same public park oh my god
so what else does it say scroll down uh
seating must provide at least six feet
of distance in all directions
everyone at the gathering should
frequently wash their hands with soap
and water like
the [ __ ] duh shared items should not
be allowed during the gatherings as much
as possible any food or beverage outside
gatherings
must be in single serve disposable
containers wear a face covering to keep
covered from
spreading when gathering face coverings
must be worn in accordance with
c d p h no c d p h
um you unless exemptions are applicable
people at gatherings may remove remove
the face covering briefly to eat or
drink
as long as they stay at least six feet
from everyone else
chanting and shouting [ __ ] snopes it
doesn't say you can't
shut your mouth so here's here's my
question here's my question joe
singing chanting shouting or and
physical exertion
significantly increases the risk of
covet 19 because these activities
increase the
risk of release of respiratory droplets
and fine aerosols near because of this
singing chanting and shouting are
strongly discouraged
but if they occur the following rules
and recommendations apply
all people who are singing and chanting
should wear a face covering at all times
while singing or chanting including
anyone who's leading a song
by chant because these activities pose a
very high risk of covet 19 transmission
phase coverings are essential to reduce
the spread so people who are singing
chanting or
exercising are strongly encouraged to
maintain physical distancing beyond six
feet
okay so joe first of all yes that's
silly you win
but here's the question thank you i like
hearing that so it's true i mean yeah
say it again jamie it says
it's true it says singing so but here's
the question though crazy
like are they just listing this to try
to be like a helicopter parent to say
this is what you should do or is there
actually an enforcement mechanism where
they're going to have the lapd
knock on your doors too many people they
can't right they can't do it they have
done that to large gatherings in
california
and these these uh people are patriots
they were having a party
and they shut down i think the sway
house i believe it's called
and they're having a party and they cut
the water off
to the tic tuck house that's yeah that's
crazy but
right aren't they when they shut it off
isn't it like these giant
[ __ ] parties where everybody's two
inches away from each other breathing on
each other yeah but you know what that's
america hey i'm not listen i'm not
arguing against it i'm just asking the
question
wasn't that their reason i have to be
near a person because it's a group dance
so you can't social distance you're not
in frame yeah
these are 17 year old millionaires they
don't give a [ __ ] about government yeah
they're not going to
they really are 17 year old millionaires
trillionaires they're fine
and they're tick-tocking i love how
they're like hey thanksgiving in the
park 30
of california is i know right see what
i'm saying with with uh
snopes like you got to be careful no no
you're right that's definitely what you
said it is is what it is
i guess my only question is enforcement
mechanism
they'll say false if it's if it doesn't
align with their ideals
i think you're 100 right my only point
was i also show caution when it's
[ __ ] fox news
because you know sean hannity is not
exactly this bastion
i think when they print on the screen it
has to be true
i worked if they had me on red eye the
the show there and
i used to wear a tie and i got to say
whatever i want i think it's a great
institution
well tucker carlson's doing something
right
it's true like he's
bill o'reilly was number one beforehand
you know that's right yeah he was number
one
[Laughter]
remember that foreign i would like to
pay the girl
who uh who got 32 million 30 for her to
give her 35
yeah just to tell the story just to find
out what he did wasn't it just like you
know he was trying to flirt and he
called a loofah falafel by accident
i think he did something that happened
that definitely happened he did do that
but i do think that for 32 million
there's bodies buried like he did
something so crazy
yeah that's so much money it's a lot of
money
she has she has like the possession in
her
possession tapes some that are like true
detective season one i mean it's bad
it's gotta be crazy when you pay that
much money you're really trying to bury
something you're guilty
you got you are guilty but he's still
doing really well with his political
show online apparently
why are you making that face because who
the [ __ ] watching bill o'reilly well
we researched this and
we reached millions of views well he
does all these books now he writes all
these books with that guy martin du gard
and the books are like killing stalin
killing killing princess die yeah
killing the woman i paid 34 million
dollars to
he he makes a lot of money he does he
makes a lot of money on those stupid
books
yeah they were best sellers who reads
old people that hate
which is why i'm surprised that his
[ __ ] thing online is doing well
because you know there's like it was all
geriatric people watching
no disrespect to geriatrics people i
love you commensurate numbers to you i
think he's doing better than you
i would be surprised if you're doing
better than me in terms of in terms of
viewership
you're doing very well but i really
think he is and where is he primarily
hosting his show well
i don't know if he's on youtube but he's
on bill o'reilly.com
right we we looked it up so here's his
own website
yeah i remember jamie and i looked it up
once that's about a year and a half ago
we were stunned by the number of views
on each page on each other
that's even more impressive if you did
it on his own website because that's
hard to do usually you have to go to
a thing that hosts it you know what i
mean like everybody knows go to youtube
and see stuff or
yeah whatever isn't it amazing that
youtube has a solid
lockdown on that i mean it is they are
the number one platform on planet earth
for people just uploading videos there's
no one even close and i don't think
they're handling the responsibility of
it well because
um they've tweaked algorithms to
de-prioritize what they call
borderline outlets and that's you that's
definitely me
now what makes you borderline because
you're not with a giant organization
i i really think that that's probably it
the fact that i don't answer to anybody
i'm my own person
i could say whatever i want whenever i
want and simply put they don't
know what's going to come out of my
mouth right but let me push back on that
they don't do anything to me then i'm
impressed
they don't seriously i'm impressed by
that but think about that i mean my
videos get
[ __ ] insane numbers they really do
they do really well how is that that
doesn't make sense i don't know man you
have to talk to them but
what i'm convinced of is that there's
different levels to
how much they prioritize you and how
much the algorithm pushes you out to new
people
and you know i've actually talked about
this we mentioned jimmy dore earlier him
and i have had a thousand conversations
about this
where we know other channels that were
similar size to us and we were chugging
along all at basically the same rate
and then out of nowhere when i was
gaining 30 or 40 000 new subscribers a
month it's flowed to 6 000.
is it possible that it's less nefarious
and that they made some sort of a
deal with just political outlets across
the board
well that is it because they admitted it
they actually released it they have this
thing where
they tell you what they're gonna do and
one of the things they said is
in order to combat fake news they want
to make sure that the stuff that gets
recommended
is the respected outlets namely cnn
fox news msnbc listen to your [ __ ] i
watch your videos all the time they
never get recommended to me
exactly well that's exactly it why don't
you go on the dark web
but because then you're saying it makes
videos
your videos get recommended occasionally
i should be really honest about this
but jimmy doors get recommended all the
time to me that could just be that you
watch more him
than me because honestly as long as
you're a subscriber and you watch my
stuff
then they will recommend it to you the
issue is they don't recommend it that
much
to new viewers so it used to be if
you're watching a cnn video or you're
watching some other
news outlet they could recommend one of
my videos because i get
i used to get better views than they do
now they pump theirs out all the time
and they surpass me so that would be
non-rel so people have never looked at
you at all yeah so that's so no
you're not getting that right right
that's right back
get this during the 2016 election 2016
i was gaining 30 to 40 000 subscribers a
month now it's like 6 000.
and other channels that are not
deprioritized
are still gaining that or more 90 000 50
do you think there's what happens if
someone like cnn
puts out information that's demonstrably
false see then that's
the next point that i was going to make
which is it's ridiculous that they even
have this notion that like
well these are the real outlets and
these are the fake outlets listen
you brought up russiagate before from
the beginning i was saying here's what's
going to happen with russiagate
absolutely nothing
the people were thinking that donald
trump was going to get pulled out of i
just followed the evidence joe
it's not that difficult you just have to
look at whatever
whatever the intelligence agencies say
usually it's [ __ ] these the same
people who lied us into the [ __ ] iraq
war and i'm supposed to listen to them
when they tell me that the president's a
manchurian candidate
right there's an old saying
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
they didn't present any real evidence it
was just a bunch of screaming idiots
like rachel maddow every night did you
see
ted cruz cross-examining comey
about uh the uh about testimony
about russia about evidence that was uh
emails that were edited
and they were the the emails were edited
to
uh to imply a completely different
outcome than that what the email
actually said yeah i did not see that
it's crazy but that's a battle of smug
[ __ ] there comey versus cruz
it is but i i really respected ted cruz
for that conversation it was stunning
yeah it was stunning it was stunning
listening to them sitting you know
comey was just basically i don't recall
that this is uh not what i'm aware of
and
and you're you know cruz reads off of
the email he reads
the actual real original email and then
he reads the email that was put into
that was uh submitted as evidence and
how it was edited yeah it's disturbing
it's
incredibly disturbing that someone in
the intelligence community could get
away with that whoever did it
whoever edited that but just to make
trouble
that's what i'm saying they lie all the
time joe just because they're you know
oh they're official and they don't
curse like i do or whatever and they
seem like they're more relaxed when they
talk
they're liars and cnn oftentimes puts
out stuff that's completely untrue
all the mainstream media outlets do and
there's you know
there's never a moment of reckoning
where it's like okay well that was fake
news actually and what the independent
guys were saying was actually correct
was it you that was telling me that
brian stelter was uh
saying don't listen to other news
outlets
i wasn't me but i do know what you're
talking about yes i was having a
conversation with someone who they were
they were telling me
that he literally was saying don't
listen to other news outlets because
they're not going to tell you the truth
we're going to tell you the truth that
sounds like a cult thing right doesn't
it
that's what it is but when when they've
been wrong
and haven't told you the truth about a
number of things that are provable look
at syria there's another great example
how long were they telling us about
syria that you know oh there was
assad did a gas attack against his own
people then you have whistleblowers
who were doing the investigations who
were like this is not true at all
yeah and then they never correct
themselves meanwhile then there's people
like me and there's people like jamie
who are like that's not
they're wrong about this and we nev we
get de-prioritized when we say stuff
like that there's never a moment we're
like oh actually they were right
it's interesting because you have to
stay independent and so does jimmy like
people like you you there's no way jimmy
dork do that show if he was on some sort
of a coordinated
can't have a boss no way too wild no i
can't have one either i'm not going to
listen to somebody tell me say this or
you don't say this but jimmy dore
like you said he spits fire he gets
crazy right yeah
he gets crazy he says wild [ __ ]
and you know like is he because he's a
comedian as well
i know yeah you can see that influence
when you talk i would like a boss i
would like to be sponsored by chase
manhattan or city group or
and they pay well out here son a company
with i hear they say well
one of the best conspiracy theories from
the podcast we did with alex
is they think that there's a woman's
voice yeah in one of the clips
saying you're we're relax we're here
we're here
but it's it's actually me i had to
double check it out what are you
thinking
i wanted to make sure i was like maybe
something slid in there but i didn't
and tim [ __ ] dylan and me that must
drive you crazy that
you it couldn't be more obvious that
there's
no steering that ship and people are
accusing you of like i don't see
somebody steering this is the most
ridiculous steering too it's
me telling alex relax we're here relax
we're here
and they're like it's a woman's voice
you hear that here's a woman's voice
like i had a friend
send this to me cameron haynes cameron
hand sent it to me he goes
play this he goes what is that voice i
go that's me [ __ ]
that's me going relax we're here relax
there's a woman's voice
there's a woman's voice i love spotify
being like listen nothing's going to
change about the show we are going to
have a woman in your ear
for three hours and she's going to tell
people to relax and tell people to relax
and she's just going to remind you that
spotify is here
i saw you other than that i saw your
video on that with the pink hair and the
ah yeah well they're fun the tech people
are fun
i mean you got to laugh at this you got
to enjoy it what i worry about is
there's far too many people
that aren't going to enjoy what's
clearly the end of the country
and it would and treat it with laughter
and i think they're going to go out and
try to kill each other and ruin
businesses and ruin property instead of
just accepting
that this was a good run that we had a
fun run as an empire
and now it's kind of coming apart but
everything's not horrible there's still
certain niceties it really is coming
apart for sure
i mean it is it is coming apart i saw
some violence today at one of the polls
in north carolina what do you got here
up there the as of this moment which
whatever
it's uh eight almost 8 30. trump is
leading the popular vote
but not the electoral college i mean
trump is ahead that's not that's not
going to hold
right 25 million there's a zero
percent chance that that holds someone
sounds like a [ __ ] expert over here
can i see the rest of the states yeah
right scroll down we see all the states
wait a minute wyoming went red that's
weird
jamie can you show me how much of the
texas vote is in by hovering over the
texas thing
63 are you [ __ ] kidding me dude but
look how close it is
yeah but democrats are supposed to lose
it by 15 points
look at it but look at it 49 to 49 49.6
to 49.1 that's real close
i know but it should be donald trump
plus 15 yeah because all my [ __ ]
[ __ ] people
moved here this is joe rogan's fault
it's not my fault but people like me
who were the looting and the pandemics
like we're done
we're out of here wait out missouri's
blue
no that's over that's not going to hold
how much is it yeah that i don't think
that's going to biden wins texas it's
over right
yes no there's no prayer for trump to
fight and wins texas
texas joe you got to pack up and go home
what do i do you got to go back he's
going to come on the podcast and he's
going to
barely speak
dem you have coherently nice few months
i think there's a reason why texas is
fun and i don't think you could have
that with a democrat you can't
yeah but like what's he gonna do he's
not gonna force texas to do
like well the last democrat was what ann
richards here
a republican look at austin disgusting
and blue just sitting there like a big
blue zit in the middle of the city
dallas all the big cities joe
god damn it that's what happens all the
big cities go left and all the rural
areas go right but isn't that the case
with i mean that's the whole reason why
new york and california we were talking
about it before that
big cities always go blue always why
usually they're younger people are
closer together um why does that make
people democratic
i mean listen there's something to be
said about when if you live
the kind of rural lifestyle it's almost
like and i don't mean this in a
derogatory way at all but i'm saying
like you're the county of the area you
know what i mean
i don't mean it like that because i'm
i'm a town i'm still in the place where
i grew up
you know just i guess not in a rural
area more in a
more city suburban type area but i'm
saying that the people that live in
cities are more civilized
no that's what i heard about that's kind
of what i heard then it did not come out
right
no i really think that there's something
to do with population density
has a lot to do with it the closer you
are to other people you feel like whoa
whoa we gotta have some rules to make
sure this thing kind of goes smoothly
whereas you don't need that many rules
when the nearest person to you is
five miles away you don't want you want
people telling you what to do
i wonder yeah i'd like to get someone
who really understands that to explain
some sort of sociologist it's always
been like that i think it's always been
more city cities you need more
government
rights
uh you are there's an interdependence in
cities that doesn't exist
outside of that that's right so when you
have that interdependence you need some
type of regulatory
uh whatever it is action that that
enforces those things so that
everybody benefits or the the great
majority of people benefit
when you're in the suburbs or the rural
areas it's kind of
people are more likely to be like hey
leave me leave me alone well that's why
it's even more fascinating that arnold
schwarzenegger a republican
was the governor at one point in time
well yeah because people had had it
right rudy giuliani got elected in new
york when people had had it yeah so i
think when people
have had well they're gonna have it
after this they're gonna have it after
this it was about there was 2800
homicides a year giuliani got in
that's like eight a day and giuliani got
elected and
and then what happened was that shift
started that that started decreasing but
aren't they tracking higher than that
now in new york they're going
to they probably will i don't know if
they're tracking higher than that but
the crime is
is skyrocketing yeah and de blasio
defunded the police
this whole idea of like if you get rid
of cops and give social workers
the the job of police it's gonna work
out well
that seems to be a little childish yeah
i
the de blasio thing seemed more like an
accounting trick
where he was trying to say to the
activists like whoa whoa whoa i did the
thing you wanted me to do
but he didn't really substantively
address the funding for the police i
sent you an article on that a while ago
right so what is the
break it down for done we could try to
pull up the article to see the details
of it but basically he just used
he shuffled money from one part of the
police department
to another agency where he could say oh
i defunded the police but the money's
being used for the same thing
it is amazing how uh blue texas looks
i'm i'm floored by that that's a
political realignment that is
wow listen they've been saying for a
long time that this might happen
i just didn't think it would happen this
quickly i didn't think it would be by
2020 that this happens
because that would mean so if texas
stays blue right he's done
he's done he's done yeah if i didn't win
texas it's over
no way there's no way there's no plan
for trump no pass if i if i if
if trump loses florida it's over
and how's he doing in florida slightly
but say they say it's too close to
colby's winning i wish there was someone
i could root for in this election i
really did
i'm having fun in the idea that trump
could win again
just because so many people that
despised mike i think are annoying
yes but i don't really want him to win
right yeah you know what you're gonna
get and it's chaos
you know chaos it's chaos with biden too
because it's
a different kind of chaos yeah i don't
even know where i am his brain doesn't
work
right but you don't worry about a tweet
at 4am i love those tweets
but then you get someone who you didn't
elect who runs the country
that's that's yeah i mean listen no no i
mean if
if biden is incompetent and you're
saying so it's the people around him
running the country
this was something that tim poole
brought up and i i didn't think he was
right but
i thought it was a weird thing to bring
up i i interesting thing i should say to
bring up the 25th amendment the idea
that the president's unfit if the
president is unfit
that they could and analyze that with
biden no no first of all
tim they tried to do this there's
democrats who were talking about doing
this
with trump yes and the point that i made
and a lot of other people made is
once you open that door of like oh i
think this person's mentally unfit
mentally incompetent so i don't care
what the voters said
i'm going to override them because i
think i'm some sort of expert yeah
there's no
shutting that door every single
president will have the opposing party
say
we're going to go after him because he's
not mentally fit but whether or not it's
true
it's not a thing where people who want
to take over power
they look at the person in power and
they try to find a way that they can do
but they don't understand that that
could be used on them
exactly this is the argument that i was
making to those dummies that were
running chas
in in seattle i was saying do you
understand now that you said
you could take people's property by
force right you can enforce your own
laws you can make your own country
inside of a country and you can put up
boundaries and borders
and you can enforce those with those raw
laws with violence
well guess what now you've opened up the
door to someone doing that to you that's
exactly right
because they don't have to have any sort
of legal precedent they don't have to
have
any legislative powers they're not they
just have force force
people struggle with doing the thought
exercises of like a universality to
their actions
you know and this is actually what i
brought up earlier with trump i always
talk about the obama campaign was spying
on me this is crazy it's like yeah
and the nsa is still spying on all
americans maybe you should do something
about that right like pardon snowden is
chas notice
assange as well part of snowden pardon
assange yeah yeah but they won't do that
you know that's uh that's the case with
but that that whole thing that you're
talking about where people
want to do something to someone and
don't understand those things can happen
back to them
that's that's that always applies to
violence absolutely i'll
go punch that guy in the head you know
like it's not there it doesn't end there
it doesn't stop there is a long domino
like you know like the violence from the
civil war that lasted for decades where
people were still murdering people
from the other side that killed their
kin folk that's your whole punch of nazi
like everybody was like punched that was
the worst listen by people who should
never even think about punching anybody
they were all running around punching
nazis
right don't you don't know how to punch
you have to think about violence and i'm
curious to know what your thoughts are
on this
in a principled way so what i mean by
that is you have to have a standard and
the standard that i've always defaulted
to
is only in cases of
self-defense from imminent attack
basically and i think that doctrine
works well in your personal life
and i think that doctrine works well as
a foreign policy for the entire country
yes that hey the only time we're going
to send people to fight and die is when
there's really some legit
threat of attack against us 100 100 i
agree 100 but i also think that the
people
that are calling for violence that don't
understand violence they're so crazy
you're literally like a child who is
calling for a fight with someone
who knows how to fight like if you call
for violence in this country
there are what are the number of
veterans in this country
i mean it's got to be more than a
million there are so
many people in this country that really
understand violence and
they're not the ones calling for
violence they're not the punch of nazi
people right
the people that really understand
violence and have seen violence and have
committed violence for their country
though
those are the [ __ ] that you
break glass in case of war
you need them and people don't
understand that like these
these people running around calling for
violence calling for a revolution
like you are going to open a door that
you can never close
and when those [ __ ] soldiers come
pouring out that door and they want to
defend what they think is an attack on
their freedoms
and their country you're [ __ ] yeah and
again
that's why i'm happy to get back to the
point i made earlier that we have so
many good distractions that i don't
think we're going to get to the point of
the civil war
god i hope not because i think netflix
kind of sucks
recently like a lot of shows are not
that good the late night
hold on i would rather do a civil war
than listen to fallon what about cope i
actually agree with that i agree with
that yeah
what about i think he agrees with that i
think fallon was like please
i know yeah give me a musket i know i'm
not good
if you watch cobra is crazy it's [ __ ]
that's great there's a few things
that
breaking news breaking news marijuana
legalization referendum way ahead in new
jersey
wow [ __ ] you chris christie how about
that chris well
listen here's a reality chris chris he's
a healthy guy and he wants to keep
people healthy he beat cove
that should be the end of the lockdown
right there he did be covered yeah
so did my friend whatever drugs they got
well i have a friend who's 80 and he
just beat it
yeah did he take the drugs he didn't
take [ __ ] took some iv vitamins
he said he was sick for four days wow
new jersey government phil murphy is
highly confident marijuana
will be legal i look at him clapping i'm
gonna get high so
joe let me give you hi asphalt that's
what i'm saying right now
let me give you i'll tell you about the
direct ballot initiatives if you want
joe
we got wheat in a bunch of places so we
got legalizing weed in
arizona yeah legalizing weed in montana
and in new jersey that's three and then
also i think we have south carol
south dakota and mississippi are voting
on medical marijuana not
legal recreational but medical they
don't even have medical there yet
um and then apparently the polls show
that all five of those are likely to
pass
yeah see what it's all about montana
this gets to a point in our last podcast
we spoke about this
direct ballot initiatives there's never
been a better idea because usually when
you put things directly to the people
they're overwhelmingly reasonable and
sensible
yeah yeah here we go dc initiative uh
81 decriminalized psychedelic plants oh
[ __ ]
wow and fungi look at the numbers 76
oh oh yeah and or in oregon they're
voting on decriminalizing all
drugs all drugs small amounts but look
at this that means in dc you're going to
be able to get mushrooms
finally oh how did the initiative do to
kidnap gretchen whitmer
where is that 82 yeah
who was it that it was alex jones who
said that it was
uh an fbi organization
and that two guys
well this is what the fbi does all the
time they they try you know they go into
a mosque and they go here's a bomb and
then they come back in and they go
you know that guy was working i mean
this is what they do they interact with
people
in dallas yeah of course yeah they they
gave him a bomb it didn't even work
yeah and this is the way they operate
and this is why like
boston bombing and all these things that
are weird and you don't know anything
about them a lot of it's because the fbi
doesn't want you to know how they
recruit
informants and how they operate they
don't want it it's dirty it's
dirty seriously a dirty business and
that's why i go crazy when people cite
the cia or the fbi as if they're these
objective like serious people bodies no
they're incredibly political
and they've been involved in a whole
bunch of shady [ __ ] and they still are
to this day it's not like
when they see like uh gay pride or you
know it's like insane
like the fbi is like yeah it's quite
like it's just it's absurd and then
liberal like mainstream liberals fall
for this horse [ __ ]
it's like corporations doing black lives
matter stuff like okay
you got black people working for you and
you're paying them a wage that they
can't even live on right did their black
lives matter
raise their [ __ ] wages right well
that's why i support
tim cook and apple because they're just
they're not doing anything wrong to art
people you know
a little slavery never hurt anybody is
anybody ever going to address that you
think
i mean if i really do believe to not to
beat that old dead horse but
if one cell phone company came along and
made a cell phone
and started [ __ ] on all these other
companies to make these phones using
slave labor say no our phones are made
by union workers
they cost more we make less but we can
sleep good at night
yeah so i i don't know because i feel
like it has to be addressed at the top
level you that's one you can't do at an
individual level or the bottom up
like market forces are not enough to
fight something like that
you actually need action from people
with authority and power
but it's also it's such a complex thing
to make a cell phone
it seems like like and also you have to
get in in verizon and 18t remember like
verizon had a deal with huawei they're
about to go nationwide with verizon and
then the government came in and said
and then boom they're gone and now
they're banned and now you can't even
buy
routers and modems and right actually
they're doing i think some sort of
anti-trust case against google now the
government sued google
i'm not sure if it's to break them up or
or whatever but i think it's about their
search engine
i think that you know listen we do have
a lot of things that are effective
monopolies
and that's a real problem that's a real
problem the consolidation of of
power well we could with a few
corporations certainly say that about
social media companies
absolutely you really say that about
twitter the twitter you know
through no fault of their own as a
monopoly it's not like they bought out
all the competition
but somehow i know that they made
something that was so effective that
nobody else really came up with a viable
alternative
and they become the number one source of
distributing hateful
messages and what's scary what's scary
is how much
like mainstream journalists view their
job
as to like run to the mods to tell them
when somebody's acting up or saying
something that's not true
you know what i mean and i know you and
glenn talked about this as something
i've talked about a lot as well that
really i mean it is the case that now
the new public square
is twitter facebook these big social
media companies
so honestly if we believe in the
principle of the first amendment of the
u.s constitution
you should expand that and basically
treat these companies like public
utilities and expand free speech
protections
to make them apply to everybody the only
time like listen direct threats of
violence we all agree you can't have
that
right but outside of that i mean if
somebody's just i'm saying no doxxing no
no threats direct threats doxing direct
threats of violence harassment
distribution of someone like if someone
breaks into your icloud and gets all
your dick pics kyle can't do that
yeah can't do that don't do that that's
wrong that's wrong but other than that
yeah i agree and i think the the problem
is that the medium
is so flawed that like it's a great way
if everybody plays
by some real moral ethical standards of
just
don't say anything to someone you
wouldn't say to their face and try to do
it in a kind way and don't try to hurt
people's feelings
if like we would all act in that like
even if you disagree with someone like
like
that's [ __ ] stupid this is why it's
dumb but people
when they read mean things it hurt it
literally does hurt them
yeah it gives them pain and we discredit
that pain we dismiss that pain as long
as it's convenient to us
now if someone is giving that pain out
to someone who's saying something that
we don't agree with then we fully
support it we love it exactly but if
someone
is dishing that pain out to someone who
we think is a protected person
then we get offended yeah we get very
offended and we apply different
standards
that's right i mean listen i just don't
read it do you read yourself no yeah i
don't read it because
when you hit a certain point it's like
oh this is not adding anything to my
life i would be an insane person me too
like every time i have a podcast
that's controversial there's thousands
of people that you can't escape it
because then the
la times will write an article and blame
you for things and you're like
i think it's important to read all of
the negative comments and then respond
and kind to them
will write an article not want to say
the l.a times some
publications will write an article based
on a couple of mean tweets
that's right a couple of mean tweets and
pretend that they're relevant
and write a whole article about it
ignoring any positive tweets or negative
tweets or
uh narrative or tweets rather that are
uh
in conflict with that yeah that's just
narrative forming but they want a
certain narrative and they're gonna
search for them
support that too because that's the
first amendment that's the freedom
to do whatever they want absolutely i
just think that we have this weird
time we're we're in this weird time this
sort of adolescent stage of information
distribution where
it's so like like with allen levinovitz
calls
uh processed information the way it's
bad for you the same way is processed
food is bad for you
and i felt like that was a really great
way of analysing making an analogy
because it's that processed food we all
agree it's like
you can eat it it's not good for you if
you do it all the time you're going to
get sick
and that's the same thing with process
information if if you're a person now
particularly during covid it's
it's a huge issue because many people
were
they they really were detached from the
outside world especially people with
compromised immune systems who are
scared to go outside
older people they just only communicate
with people online
and so you're just doing you're
communicating with people through
facebook messages
and you know and you're just [ __ ]
arguing with people and don't no one is
you don't see anybody no one's in front
of you
and how many people are even good at
that right we're so bad at that just
talking face-to-face people are bad yeah
kellyanne conway just came out said you
will hear from the president tonight
oh that means he's probably going to try
to declare victory i i'm wondering if
that is the case
but kellyanne is saying that on twitter
[ __ ]
there you go that's more what i thought
yeah what happened
i'm just listen i'm not even rooting for
anybody this is always why this
yeah it doesn't sound like you are yeah
really
anyway i don't uh yeah 66
though there could be more um yeah but
it won't be it's gonna
it's gonna lean red but i'll tell you
right now maybe the last election
republicans can
safely say they have taxes oh yeah they
barely got it now they barely got it now
we're nowhere near what is the numbers
jamie go back to that as far as
percentage
counted yeah it's only 66 they could
lose it already still
look 34 is a lot of [ __ ] people it's
like four three two four two three nine
that's nice
34 is a lot and imagine all these
[ __ ]
liberals out here that came with me from
from california that yeah
yeah they haven't moved yet so florida's
going to trump wow kansas went red how
weird
florida's going to trump yeah i think
the ones that are
and bold red colors they've called yes
they've called our
yeah i'm kidding about kansas of course
it's red now what about ohio
so it looks like florida's red see ohio
that's more reflecting what the polls
were it showed trump a little bit up now
trump's up in ohio so wait let me see
let me see this
ohio florida texas what else is
pennsylvania he needs pennsylvania
he's not going to pay pennsylvania if he
doesn't get pa can he get anything else
to make up for pa
uh go to pennsylvania maybe but he
doesn't it's not possible like he would
he could jack nevada but that's not
going to be good enough he's way off in
pennsylvania though look at that only 17
percent reporting yeah but no no he
actually that's not terrible because
they count i think they count the
mail-ins first there
well look at this hold on let me let me
fact-check that it's only 17
but he's off by what is that 50 there's
time
thousand there's time sixty thousand
there's a lot of time there's a lot left
to report a lot of farmers
what about california hold on how's
california pennsylvania pennsylvania
i think still open it's only go to
california six o'clock it's nothing
there yet go to excuse me go oh
you're right about pennsylvania joe
you're right about pennsylvania
they count the results are released
from election day first and then they do
the mail-in so if i didn't already has a
lead then that's looking good for bites
it's a problem
and if biden wins pennsylvania he's got
it that's it
well the weird thing is though
pennsylvania is 17 reported
pennsylvania might be one of those
they're a slow counter they're slow
counter they are
because they had to wait to count the
melons or is there anything
or we see the governor of pennsylvania
driving a ferrari in two weeks and biden
wins
is there is there yeah with a new laptop
he's got a [ __ ]
covered is there any way that trump wins
the popular vote and loses the electoral
college less than a one percent chance
okay
but there's a popular vote right now
what do we what are we at jamie
it doesn't matter what it is now it's
again not going to write no what did i
just
know i got a question he's ahead 0.2
million he's ahead by a million you know
so this is just
i know a lot it's just kind of looking
like
biden looks like biden if it gets
pennsylvania no no no not for nothing
right now this
is not terrible for trump okay the the
only issue for him as of this moment
is pennsylvania what if he gets nevada
arizona he's not he's not going to get
one he can't win no no can't win
no way he can win without pennsylvania
florida those those two are
so super important for florida it's
gonna get florida
it looks like he's got florida but if he
loses pennsylvania that's a wrap
that's a wrap that's right there's
really no other path they're lying and
saying oh maybe we can win nevada
they're not winning nevada he's eight
more than eight points down in nevada
let's see nevada
what's nevada i'm saying in the polls i
don't they didn't even close you out
close yet so weird man
it's all so weird let's do a monarchy
you know what i mean like this isn't
every every year this is enough already
let's just do a king and a queen like
the king of thailand
that kind of deal right so is it
official concubine
somebody that can figure it out you want
me to give you the best
numbers for trump yes okay i'll give you
the best numbers for trump
there's some evidence out there that
he's still
got it he's still got a shot so when
pollsters ask
are you better better or worse off than
you were four years ago
fifty percent say better only thirty
four percent say worse
that's crazy because you gotta be worse
than you were eight months ago that's
what i'm saying too but this is what the
poll shows an nbc news wall street
journal poll is totally legit
the last time an incumbent lost better
pulled at 37
and worse pulled at 40 and that was
george hw bush in 1992.
it's tricky there's also a big
enthusiasm gap
so only 46 percent of biden supporters
strongly support him
66 percent of trump supporters strongly
support him i'm amazed the 46 percent of
biden supporters i think
39 of them are lying yeah most of them
are lying
yeah they don't hate trump they like
kamala and they hate trump yeah i think
they'd have a better chance if kamala
was on the ticket
in the front i think it was kamala
versus trump they'd have a better shot
you said it already yourself this is
really just somebody who's not trump
that's the whole mindset right but
kamala harris at least
we call it kamala that's rude it's
kamala is it
not not like the wrestler from back in
the day kamala
kamala she i think she'd have a better
shot on her own
i don't know because she she got
absolutely obliterated in the primary
yeah but that was because tulsi
sanctuary
it wasn't just tulsi she also went from
pretending to be
like a lefty like bernie sanders and
talking about healthcare for everybody
and then by the end of the campaign
she was begging to for donald trump to
get banned off twitter as if that's some
sort of like principled stand
yeah what was that about she has no
political instincts and the idiots
around her were like hey
use this as your main issue like getting
banned used to putting people in jail
she's just sitting in a twitter jail
do you see that weird conversation she
had with rachel maddow where she
pretended to see the fly
on mike pence's head and was laughing
about it but it's so
obvious that it's fake it's the weirdest
conversation
it's so weird did you see when colbert
was asking her about her strong lines of
attack against biden
it was a debate right he's like so you
didn't mean what you were saying
it was a debate and he let her off the
hook
it's like at least [ __ ] us well yeah
you know
don't but give us that that's a that's a
crazy thing imagine a debate
yeah it's like this before i let you go
if
you noticed the flashlights on vice
president pence's head at the time
or if that was something that only we
could see it at home could you see it
sitting next to him watch this look at
this
oh i made that up
did you have feelings about like did you
have
the instinct to hard-hitting journalism
you know right
that is i just you know i think that
it's important that we kind of
um find a way all of us to move on
stop that's the fakest laugh i've ever
heard in my life
that's like a producer laugh when you're
doing a sitcom run through that jokes
lane max will have so much more
integrity than these people
here's the thing there's a long history
of flies landing on candidates
in elections or in in debates one landed
on hillary didn't want to run on hillary
and debate with
trump and uh there's another one there's
another one in the past
oh [ __ ] it's happened with obama before
too
um it has and i remember alex jones
saying that's evidence that he's a demon
[Music]
he he said that anyone that he was like
hillary smells like sulfur
yes yes that's it he said that hillary
smells like soul friend it'll be a
little bit closer
someone took him saying all those things
and put it in a song
i did see that it was hilarious there's
a fly it lands on obama's lip
i mean how fun is that it's so weird
it's weird that flies land on people and
debates and then we make a big deal of
it
and that becomes the number one right as
opposed to the substance
the policy of what they're discussing
that's nothing that's boring that fly
lands it on a pence's head he's a piece
of [ __ ]
i do blame the media people even
understand policy like if somebody came
up to me and were like
what i would be like wait what it's so
hard to understand the intricacies of
like
a particular policy yeah and it's so
difficult for most people
that are working and they have kids and
they're trying to get by to really know
like i mean healthcare healthcare being
explained to anyone it's crazy
right where's the money going where's
the money going nobody knows i think
you're definitely right about that
but also wrong in one sense which is
people people generally their gut
instinct is usually
correct about the direction we should
take the cut that's true you know what i
mean
like oh we've been in afghanistan for 19
years should we still be there
probably not like that's what people
said if you tell them yeah but we're
getting them we're getting the medals
for the
phone they go oh
and they go back to work like this but
they don't say that you sat down to go
getting the medals for the phone there
they go right okay
but then but the argument they really
use is out of we're fighting for your
freedom or something
right so if you said is slave labor good
they will go no
okay give me your phone oh
hold on okay yeah no i think
you know like healthcare is another one
if you bring up healthcare you think hey
should everybody in the country have
healthcare
yes you know where's that money come
from yes
every other developed country has health
care for their people
oh they say it actually saves money
that's something that but i think so if
you ask that question i think you're 110
right but if you phrase it another way
and you're like socialize medicine
well or should should you not be able to
get private insurance right people would
say no i don't want that
right that's right it is all in the
framing you can get whatever answer you
want
if i really felt like my taxes were
going to good i'd feel good about paying
i always said that too that's right
and that's the problem then it goes to
bail out wall street bailouts military
industrial complex also you don't get a
receipt
like they don't show you yeah you know
like if you if you get a receipt if you
could
imagine if americans could opt in on
what you put your butt like i want all
my money to go to education
like you know a certain person like like
then you realize what what people give a
[ __ ] about and what they don't give a
[ __ ] about and
right you vote for that right vote for
where your taxes go
and that's actually why i think in many
other like european countries they don't
necessarily view taxes the same way that
we do because they actually tangibly see
what they're getting for that money
they see that they get the health care
they see that they get the education
they see that they have you know paid
vacation time by law for example does
every other country
every big country have uh socialized
medicine other than us
yes every other developed country has
one version
of universal healthcare yes they vary in
terms of how they do it so here i'll
give you an example
like the uk for example they have what's
called the national health service
nhs and basically that's public funding
of public hospitals public doctors
public institutions
so in other words everything is the
government when you go to the nhs and
when you go to the doctor
right and then there's examples like i
think canada's like this and france is
like this
where you have public funding of private
institutions
so you have private doctors they have
their own practices you can have private
hospitals it's their own thing
but it's funded through tax dollars so
that's a little bit different and how
they structure it
so there's various ways to do it and get
to universal health care
but the connecting tissue is funded
through taxes
publicly funded and that's
you know that creates some problems of
its own
right like what what do you think well
if you have
in the uk for example they have people
coming in when you don't have the tight
immigration standards you have people
coming in from other countries
getting operations that haven't paid
into the system at all
there's an old saying that becomes a
problem there's an old saying like a
brexit fan
you can either have a welfare state and
borders or no welfare state and
no borders so then why do you have the
squad and aoc and all these people
they know bernie sanders said the same
thing about immigration he said open
borders is called
brother's proposal that's right
everything trump has said about
immigration was uttered by
bill clinton and a lot of it by barack
obama actually deported more than trump
why is this id pile identity politics
like run gone so insane on the left yeah
can't have an
actual conversation about immigration
depressing wages without calling people
nazis social social media there's
definitely with social media you could
shut someone down by simply saying
that they're racist it doesn't seem a
desire to seem designed like that aoc
and all these people are the
pro open borders and it seems like for
what i would actually contest that i
don't think they're actually for
open borders but they say they are she
said i'm for open borders she's
very any curbing of immigration the
discussion of it is shut down
immediately by
by her i agree with that i agree that
the discussion is usually shut down it's
difficult to open borders if they don't
say open borders they say well you can
come over and show up
for a hearing but you're not going to
show up for a hearing because you're we
let you in so that
you could say it's not open borders but
it's de facto open borders if there's no
enforcement
so she's against any type of enforcement
so if i said tomorrow
there's no enforcement for drunk drivers
but hey
don't drive trump that that's de facto
pro trump
i think i think the distinction they
make is criminally
punishable versus civil punishment and
so they say don't treat it like the
criminal matter treated more like a
civil manner now
overall listen i'm not yeah how do you
get money from people though that come
over the
to the country how do you treat like a
civil matter uh
as in you don't lock them up in a cage
necessarily it does happen i don't know
you'd have to ask them i don't have the
same position they have so i'm just
saying yeah but i'm saying that's the
problem with a lot of people when you
look at that flank of the democratic
party
and you go it would be great to have
health care and all these things however
you can't just have poorest borders
no enforcement it's like crazy to think
you could do that it is sort of
overstated though
how much they've put on this issue it's
not like democrats when they get in
their local meetings they're like
we sure should open the borders they're
talking more about health care i'll tell
you they're talking more about that is
the reason that trump wanted it is the
most popular issue if you look at the
numbers and ann coulter puts all these
numbers up all the time
well over 70 percent of people blacks
hispanics everybody
including recent immigrants favor
curbing immigration
they do not want just unfettered
immigration
that's that's pretty like that's pretty
proven
every single time the question is and
obama broke the deportation record
right obama deported more people than
trump deported i'm just wondering
why it's become this this hot button
issue where
everybody who wants to talk about it is
a racist nazi when
literally obama you know understood that
you needed a border
well here it's real simple it's real
simple trump is president trump's a
republican
trump's already been labeled a racist
then you have these cages
you see people in the cages it looks
terrible and you see
children being separated from their
parents it seems terrible it is
but supporting any sort of curbing of
immigration
supports that so in right it's already
been established right well listen see
what i'm saying
i do see what you're saying listen i
think that
i agree with you people should be clear
no i don't support totally open borders
then you literally don't have a country
right so you can't be in favor of that
but should we have
a process to get in here should the
process make sense and be humane
you know should we like i i do think
that the thing about kids in cages they
were in
cages under the previous administration
and they're in cages under this
administration
i do think it's a genuine humanitarian
concern when people see that and they're
like oh man i don't think that looks
like that's a horrible thing
right now and i should say real clearly
when i say trump's been established as
being racist i mean by them
right
by saying the thing what did he say
about mexicans about the mexicans uh
criminals they're rapists i assume some
are good people no
he was saying the ones that sneak over
here legally there's a lot of gang
members to sneak over here
that's not even backed up by the
evidence that's demagoguery that's not
even true okay
when you talk about sheer numbers or
that there are
some that come on there are some but his
argument was not that there are some
he said they're criminals they're
rapists and i quote i assume
some are good people in other words he
flipped it you're saying
yeah they come in here yeah right you're
saying some of them are criminals and
rapists
he's saying the default is their
criminals and rapists and i assume some
are gonna be
clear why they're criminals they're
criminals because they don't have
anything going on in their country they
come over here because we have
crazy drug laws and the drug war that's
right that's right the whole thing if
you
legalize drugs it sounds crazy to people
that don't want their kids to be hooked
on drugs and i have kids and i don't
want my kids to be hooked on drugs but
if you legalize drugs you would
essentially take the legs off of
organized crime
100 that's literally what funded right
al capone
right that's literally what funded all
the moonshine runners it was the fact
that it was illegal
and it's it propped up organized crime
in this country isn't so much of the
police state that we have
kind of i guess dependent on these silly
laws being enforced and a lot of people
are drawing
a salary and forcing those laws 100 a
big part of what keeps marijuana illegal
is the
prison guards unions right they they try
to keep
they want jobs right they want jobs they
want people in jail
which is crazy if you really think about
it we just get into a problem where it's
like there's not enough jobs right now
and that's a real problem
if you unwind what you should all these
unfair systems
you're gonna have a hell of a lot of
people with nothing to do that's not
true you're gonna have a hell out of a
lot of people who could sell wheat
like look what's going on right there's
a lot of people legally that are selling
wheat yeah
prisoners only fans
and now we got a podcast and now we sell
pot now we do it yeah listen there's
there's a lot of things that people can
do the idea that the only the thing
they're doing now is the only thing they
could do is ridiculous
we're treating them like their children
right but we're treating human beings in
prison when you when you're talking
about private prisons and you're talking
about people generating money by people
in jail you're treating human beings
like organic batteries that generate
coins for you it's literally what it's
like it's the most disgusting thing that
we've ever done as a culture
is make it so there's more laws that
keep people in jail because you can make
money off those people in jail
it's right it's the it's one of the
darkest things we do
by the way i think it would have been
great if you know
trump and if he might win a second term
but i'm saying if he decided
we spoke about this just legalize
marijuana take it off the schedule
take it off as a schedule one substance
or at least decriminalize it
that would have been awesome because
there's so many people on the right that
don't want that
only evangelical christians and he's
already got them locked up no no no it's
a lot of [ __ ]
hard-working right-wing really ted
nugent man me and ted nugent got into it
over pot
you know because he's like one of those
guys that thinks like you know hard
working hard playing americans you don't
want pot you want dope to be out there
killing your motivation like
ted i smoke a lot of weed i have three
jobs i work out all day like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about man this is
nonsense
yeah like you've got these stereotypes
in your head the polls are clear though
it's
over 60 percent want that so if trump
did that it'd be popular the tide has
turned
right if you went back 10 years ago it
would be something that wasn't sent
away yes that's true because it's
information people are getting
information
but by the way i don't think it's safe
for everybody
uh and i've said this as a person who
smokes a lot yeah i get paranoid i was
telling you that's what happens to me
is okay i think it's good for you i
think
i don't know about that i think it's
good for you i think it makes you when
you the paranoia wears off
you have a greater appreciation of life
i look at paranoia like little baby
near-death experiences
you have an opportunity to be a good
person when you survive i think
marijuana can be a gateway drug it led
me through the gateway to infowars
and i and that was a good part of mine a
big part of my life the weird the thing
about
it that i'm concerned with the
schizophrenia i'm legitimately concerned
with it
from personal experiences not myself but
friends i know
people that have had uh particularly
people that didn't smoke pot and were
given edibles
and had these schizophrenic breaks uh
not not just one either multiple people
that have had like like really good
people
good solid people with like real
ambitious
had their [ __ ] together someone gives
them an edible uh this will help you
sleep and
someone [ __ ] up and gives them like 100
milligrams or something like that joey
diaz numbers
joey diaz is ruined of a bunch of people
that's what he does he thinks it's funny
when he he's like
he thinks when you look edible what
happens it just unwinds
you start hallucinating not not me not
you
but maybe me listen some people have a
alex barrenson wrote a book about it and
he debated uh
dr mike hart from the uk
who are excuse me from canada rather who
is a
uh cannabis doctor and you know he had
some good points but
alec berenson alex peterson wrote a book
about it and he came on the podcast to
talk about it and i agree with them
for some people and it's not a small
number i mean it might be one percent i
don't know what it is there's actually a
study on this yes that i spoke about
there is a small percentage that
you know it leads to schizophrenia it
leads to schizophrenia or
people that have a tendency to
schizophrenia exacerbates it and that's
why when i
you know i used to smoke every now and
then oh jamie's got something to raise
his face i'm looking at something that
this is not the best thing to be judging
the election office
but i'm looking at snopes it's
definitely not snopes
um i'm looking at a couple different uh
betting websites
live betting that's going on to trump
for sports swung to trump he's now
on one side i saw as high as minus 800.
what does that mean eight to one eight
hundred dollars to win a hundred dollars
on that
bet so trump's losing no that's been a
huge favor oh he's winning
and it was biden before the before today
started so
it's been back and forth let's take a
look at that long heavy to trump oh
[ __ ] um
listen he absolutely can win this guy
very sad
would you just be sad if he won this
site shows i'm gonna be miserable no
matter what the [ __ ] happens we got a
guy who's a zombie and a guy who's a
[ __ ] bloated demagogue i just want
candace owens to be happy
oh shelby is going to be very happy
she's going to be very happy
so we're trying to facetime her i'm
trying to get her number right now you
were i want to face tomorrow
at the end of it to just you know you
don't have her number i have i
have her manager's number her manager
sent her my number
oh okay you see that's gonna be funny
you just face timer
get it get an update from candace and
daily wire the only thing that makes me
happy is the people that are gonna be
upset
well that's the whole thing and some of
the trump people i hate too
but i hate both sides so i can get happy
no matter what
like no matter who wins i can lay in bed
tonight go you know what
good good good you know i was gonna vote
for kanye
yeah i'm like i want to make it
stick to my tradition if trump wins
again because you
you articulate this stuff better than
anybody what is the lesson
democrats should learn if any the uh the
one they should learn versus what
they'll actually learn are totally
different
what they'll what they'll do is they'll
say ah we [ __ ] up we should have got
somebody who was more pro-establishment
we should have got somebody who was
further right-wing we should have
somebody who's more like
trump and like the republicans that's
what they'll do and that's what they'll
think
what they actually should have done is
realize that hey you guys jacked it from
bernie sanders in 2016.
this time around bernie sanders won the
first three primaries and then what
happened
mayor pete and amy klobuchar dropped out
and endorsed biden at the very last
minute because obama gave him a phone
call and told him to do it
so they threw all the votes behind biden
like that and then elizabeth warren
stayed in germany and elizabeth warren
stayed in and siphoned votes from bernie
and then it ended up that biden you know
burns just crushed from there on out
joe he won the election he could have
won the election in 2016.
he could have won and also obviously
this time so now listen
dirty the real lesson should have been
oh my god you should have went with
bernie but
they're not going to learn that lesson
they're going to go with [ __ ] amy
klobuchar they're going to go with comma
harris again
something along those lines what if they
could pump bernie up with steroids and
growth hormone and
nad and like just back his aging up at
length in his telomeres
keep him alive a little is it possible
give him some of the trump stuff give
him some adderall
get him on some adderall some steroids
right give him those dance moves
in the ymca it's fun to stay they're
like i'm crying
they're like i'm crying i'm just sitting
here i'm so
proud of whatever state trump lost you
know they're like i'm crying she was
crying
who knows everybody that we know they're
all crying they all did nice things they
all like led a person to you know like i
found an old woman who was blind and i
led her to the polls i tweeted earlier
today i said i i uh helped the blind
nazis
okay i i got something for you guys um
uh uh there are 270 000 mail ballots in
philadelphia county that won't be
counted until tomorrow at the earliest
and those
are very likely overwhelmingly pro-biden
because they had they have a law you
couldn't start counting until very late
so biden wins pennsylvania it's over
that's right yeah
and it looks like he's winning what's he
at now let's see what pennsylvania is at
now yeah let's take a look
so we were at 17 about 45 minutes ago
was that how long ago how long did we
look at it not that long ago
20 could have been 20 half hour whatever
27 okay let's look at it now 27 in
and it's red oh [ __ ] it's flipped
pennsylvania's red [ __ ]
that's it no but here's the thing that's
it it's over kyle
that's the one look at him he's angry
look at his face
don't commit acts of violence i'm flying
out of the state
get me the antifa face mask okay if he
gets it though
if he gets pennsylvania he absolutely is
one
he's one real he could win if he does
that for sure it looks like he's one to
me
you gotta count all the mail-ins man
yeah but wait a minute hold on
it's only 27 reporting and you got to
count all the mailings which they're
just telling you they didn't do the most
irresponsible
election show of all time no bro come on
this is actually don't disrespect my
expertise you're
here and the fact that alex had things
to do
it's balanced out is alex voting
somewhere he's definitely voting uh
i heard he's a big biting guy heard he
loves biden yeah
yeah trump's trying to stop baby eaters
look at that mane man mangoes red huh
always right
real rural wisconsin
wisconsin is kind of liberal no yeah but
again those
are all the on the day votes without
counting the mailings yet
so when they count the maryland's
wisconsin and michigan are going to go
to biden
what does wyoming 100 go to trump 75
they've already called it and there's 4
000 votes counted
it's like it's 4 000 votes it's like new
york or california it's just guaranteed
to be republican but look at the numbers
there's 4 000 votes that's that's
everybody there though
that's a show that's the whole time and
i would do this yes tim and i
did a show there we would do a show for
everyone there yeah
if we do a show in tim it would
literally be for all the voters it'd be
for the three electoral votes yeah we'd
probably get more people
than voted i bet we could get more
people i'm telling you right now i'm
gonna come out with a prediction right
now early and say i think it's gonna be
trump
i think it's gonna be trump i think he's
going to be trump yeah
i think he's going to win too i think
he's 578 000
in the whole state and there's only 4
000 people have voted
the governor's mark gordon my friend the
doctor he's the governor i didn't know i
got to call him dude the supreme court's
gonna be all conservatives
it already is it's six three i know but
it's getting it's gonna be oh you're
saying it's gonna be nine nine at the
end nobody's gonna be they're gonna kill
off the
liberals i don't know well they're gonna
i don't know what's gonna happen
i don't know what that means was it you
know what it means hold on
kanye west voted for himself but i won't
vote as a kanye west unless he puts in
more work what yeah
but it won't count as a vote for kanye
west unless he puts in more work what
does that mean that's what i'm saying i
don't know what that means
oh that's right that's just wyoming he's
got a spot while that's where he lives
that's why
he doesn't live there permanently like
all the time he lives in california as
well
i mean he does have a ranch there he's
got a gigantic like 4
000 acre ranch there ball in i had a
dream that i moved to wyoming
we there was a rumor you did move to
wyoming people like joe bought a ranch
in wyoming
really people just say things that
you've done that aren't true
is that weird being my friend and you
hear these rumors no i just i just go oh
okay good for him like they're like joe
bought this club he lives in wyoming now
oh sorry he's moderating a presidential
debate i'm like good
what do you do do you de diffuse it no i
just like that
that's what i did because the people
that are saying it i don't take
seriously anyway
by the way lindsey graham has officially
won re-election oh
lindsey graham was up against mcconnell
and mitch mcconnell that was a give it
it was no
i mean this race was actually there was
a chance for the other guy who runs
against these guys i mean they're so
pathetic
amy mcgrath and amy mcgrath should have
been defeated by a guy named i think
it's charles booker
who was a much better candidate but she
edged him out in the primary and then
she guaranteed loss to mcconnell in two
seconds when is pelosi up it's only
i saw it flipped pelosi um she's being
primaried right now by a guy by the name
of shahid batar
right now yes i believe right now i mean
she's gonna
win she's going to win in this election
i believe so i believe shahid batar's up
this election let you look that up let
me take a look
trump baby he could do it and this is a
real
interesting moment in american history
how many guns are you gonna get if
you i'll get one or two do you have one
now i don't have one now but i should
get one when you move here you're gonna
get a gun
if if he wins you have to move here
right
no i'll wait a little i'm gonna wait a
little i'm not saying no i'm saying i
gotta wait a little bit
pelosi's up now i gotta i gotta you know
she's up
well no she's up as in she's up for real
meaning she's awake
no she's not she's up like this yeah in
the coffin
she just got up like a vampire dude i'm
telling you right now this is going to
be the moment in the night we're all
going to say it when it turns to trump
first results in 45 minutes for that oh
okay first results i just lost that how
could she
possibly lose right district 12.
this is going to be a really interesting
next couple of days i really wish sean
is flying out early in the morning
because i think some of the people in
austin are going to get
fun nah this place doesn't get that fun
during downtown you don't think they're
going to get a little wacky no the cop
listen the governor here doesn't [ __ ]
around man he takes care of [ __ ]
if they think that something's gonna
happen they'll do something about it
what i'm amazed
is that there's not a revolution in san
francisco i have some friends that just
got back from san francisco and
uh they they used to live there right
and they hadn't been in a while and they
just went back
and the [ __ ] horror stories by the
way very lefty
right left-leaning people and they were
and they were
furious and what's going on gassed and
they were like i can't believe it
there's literally [ __ ] and needles
everywhere tents
everywhere they were like whatever it
was like the last time they were there
they were there about two years ago they
think they said and it was getting bad
right but they said it's unrecognizable
so i have another
update here for you uh there's a
democratic senator
by the name of doug jones in alabama and
he was just unseated by a
republican tommy tuberville so i
definitely project guy's name at all
tuberville
what's that he's a football coach what
is ohio doing right now the real
supervillain or another tuberville
republican tommy tuberville has defeated
democratic senator doug jones he looks
like an
adam sandler character yes he does like
in a movie
it seems like a fake name i don't coach
very fake so the head football coach
yeah doug jones won a special election
um and so he barely made it and it's
alabama it's a miracle that a democrat
won in alabama anyway
and so now the republican took the seat
back tommy tuberville
now what about ohio because ohio is is
is a pivotal state
well there was a projection right that a
lot of things were going to go
democratic this term yes
this i could tell you which the uh which
which states were predicted to go which
way which one do you want to know ohio
was predicted to go to trump
really yes he was up he was up in the
average of polls there
and iowa as well was predicted to go
trump what's this ohio
pulled up ohio 80 reported trump up
ohio trump's got fifty thousand votes
see that's enough that's trump so far
trump is
outperforming the polls by two percent
which is pretty pretty solid go over
pennsylvania real quick because that's
big right pennsylvania's a big one
look at that pittsburgh philadelphia all
the places that you'd expect blue
allentown that's interesting i think the
male ballots kyle said are 200 some
thousand that are heavily biden that
could definitely
yeah so again what they're doing in
pennsylvania michigan
and wisconsin like all those states joe
they're counting the
votes on the day first and then the
mail-ins come later
so it's gonna look like trump is up at
first but especially when it comes to
wisconsin
and michigan trump's going to lose
because biden's up big in those states
they're almost safe blue states
interesting because it's red now so
it'll be
because that's all the votes from today
right and those always skew more
republican
interesting and but again there's places
where it's the opposite like in the sun
belt for example they count them the
other way
how did you learn all about this stuff
did you go to school for it no
i no i'm kidding researching reading
about all this stuff
um but how did you get into it
i mean i i did go to school for
political science and you know like i
said
my kind of had my political awakening
with the iraq war and ever since then
i've just cared a lot about
what's going on because i thought it was
crazy i thought it's great we're going
to go to war with the country that
didn't attack us
and we're going to be there you know
we've been there two decades now
i was like i was what are we doing up on
long island and really drunk and i
thought the iraq war was a great idea
because and i was i would argue with
people in the bars in long island i
would say we have to honor our
commitment to the people of iraq
so do you not understand a little bit
why it was
not such a horrible idea there's a lot
of people poke is supposed to make you
anti-war
not pro-war what are you talking about
we were i thought we were doing the
right thing
why would you think coke would make you
anti-war
oh because you're just happy no you're
angry oh you're angry
coke people listen when i'm happy angry
when i'm just the best kind of happy
they want to start
when i did have businesses at the same
time when i did adderall it was just the
businesses
it wasn't the fights yeah it was
business how long did you do adderall oh
i never did it regularly but i would do
it in college
right now i dabbled i tasted it i tasted
it i dabbled
so tim do you have any pills you maybe
could hook me up no i wish i don't if
i'm sober now i have nothing that's a
shame i have
nothing you've been sober for quite a
while 10 years that's amazing over 10
years no lapses at all no lapses at all
what was like to come to jesus moment i
bought a house
when i was 22 years old for 700 000 and
i didn't have any money
and i woke up the next day and i said
this is a real problem
most people wake up to some like they
wake up next time
they wake up next to a woman that
they're like what happened here
i woke up in a 600 000 house that i had
no idea how to really pay for it
but i was investing in myself and i
think anyone that didn't take out a big
mortgage in 2007 was a [ __ ]
and i still think that and [ __ ] you you
should learn how to live
learn how to live wait yeah when the
crash came what were your thoughts were
you like oh this was gonna happen well
my thoughts were i'm in a little bit of
trouble
and uh but i you know i was like i'm
just gonna ride it out and and
and and just keep keep on keeping on and
because i was working for a guy that
said just don't read the news and
keep on trucking what did you think when
nancy pelosi said that regardless of
what the numbers are
we're going to elect joe biden as
president did you see her
i did not see that i saw hillary say
something along the lines of don't
concede under any circumstances
something like that pelosi took it
another level
she said well she's a little bit like
with assaults where she's a zombie
like her brain's not firing on all
cylinders well she's a little bit more
elusive than he is now i've seen videos
that are just as bad as the biden videos
where she's
really having trouble yes did you see
her bark at wolf blitzer
i did see that in fact i covered that
was the first time wolf blitzer's ever
done a good job basically was that video
yeah he he
basically he was basically saying like
people need money
there's we don't have the ability to
[ __ ] around here
and you know she basically couldn't she
didn't have an answer she'd have a
straight answer but she also was
chastising him and being real that's
right to him yeah that's right
it was really weird like expressing yes
like almost
royalty yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm so
sorry you're wrong about this
yeah that's what she said remember
who used to like climbing nancy pelosi's
window and stuff
like that lunatic she was fun though i
liked her but
nancy pelosi never like nancy's like
like she doesn't have any human
she's just a million years old she looks
like this porcelain a weird grandma
she's got great eyebrows she's got good
good eyebrows but nobody knows what her
dick is she's worth
millions of dollars her husband's like a
tax ceo or something yeah see that
that's kind of crazy the uh
when you see how she'll run for
something yeah she won the primary in
florida
damn it she lost she just got draxed yo
lois frankel just
beat laura loomer that's the big that's
the big race of the night oh lois
damn it laura loomerson is gonna have to
go back to climbing and nancy flows
she can't win in florida god yeah
florida's a that's a loomer country
you can't do it there isn't that amazing
though that she won the primary
yeah why not there's a lot of q a on
people that are now winning like
primaries
listen it's the trumpification of
politics and that you can kind of wing
it but if you have a better
like presentation than the other people
like yeah you can win all these old
politicians yo you know this they're so
stodgy and stuck up and they're
two scripted and then you guys what is
this q and on supporting other [ __ ]
papa
q and on supporting candidate major mor
marjorie how do you say her name
marjorie
marjorie taylor green guaranteed a
congressional win
she didn't win she did win she did win
cueing on candidate oh well her opponent
dropped out
oh
they probably threatened him so
everybody on twitter is convinced now
that
trump's going to get it so that's what i
see on twitter
what are people thinking is the sock
ladies people are live
2016 all over again the lady with the
glasses and the sock hat in the street
it was the polls went one way yeah and
then the crowds what did i say
at the beginning of this [ __ ] podcast
you said
trump's gonna win i said he's gonna win
yes he's gonna win i don't believe the
polls only morons
answer polls right and the media is
insanely biased against him and they
think that
by saying that he can't win and he's not
going to win that somehow though they
could hit the times
we just went through this period of time
with the media we watched things burn
down and people's property get destroyed
and the media said it wasn't happening
it's not happening again if you bring it
up you're nuts
also there's a psychology of fence
sitters psychology offenses
they don't want to vote on losers and
then they want to be like uh
i went trump you know i was i was
thinking i was thinking and
effect is real it's super real so when
the media is gaslighting you and saying
it looks like 99 percent yeah that
joe biden is going to win jawbot into a
stronger candidate he's going to win all
these
and then and then people hear that they
go well i might as well vote for the
winner
and they'll vote right it does happen
with people i mean this is interesting
because it we did
this has made a significant turn now to
where it feels like there's an
inevitability a little bit about
trump's second term this is the opposite
of the young turks
candidate young turns coverage of 2016.
dude i'm just waiting for alex jones to
bust in here with cigars
jesus christ he's doing his own live
show i do think that people are kind of
getting ahead of themselves because we
are seeing
the mailing votes versus the votes on
the day oh listen to the communists
okay there be
questions yeah if if some marijuana
seems like it's passed in
uh new jersey officially for those over
21.
it's being it's i've only been to new
york a couple times being so close to
new york city isn't it
almost by default not going to be legal
there because of how close it is and
like people just travel
better in terms of purchasing it no not
necessarily but bringing it in and
smoking it yeah
i can see that for sure but there's a
there's an issue with the alcohol lobby
in new york where they actually paid the
politicians quite a bit of money
and that's one of the reasons why you
haven't seen much chatter about it in
new york versus other
states dude new york is dirty they have
so much corruption they kept
the ufc out for decades we were we were
stuck because of unions
they they kept us out because it was the
there was
all sorts of disputes and people went to
jail because of it for corruption
there's so much dirtiness with those
with some
some of the union not that unions are
bad right i'm so i support a lot of
unions
a lot of people are you know that are in
these positions
they're not doing what's best for people
they're doing what whatever the [ __ ]
this person
paid them to pass or not pass and not
let past
i mean mma was legal in every other
state for a long [ __ ] time
right and new york was one of the last
ones well new york has always just be
been that you know kind of
institutionally corrupt place
yeah chicago i'm getting triggered
because you're bashing my home
new york hey i love my new york too i
know you actually
where i grew up is where you are i used
to live in new york that's right that's
where i grew up
i was born in new jersey i mean i'm east
coast yeah i spent most of my young
years in boston well from
13 to 24 at least my high school years
all through boston and you kicked the
boston accent
yeah well i kicked it because i saw
myself on tv when i was 19. when i was
i won the baystate games in taekwondo
and then i hurt myself on tv and i was
like oh my god so i went to the cafe
i was like we were working really hard
oh my god
i did but you know look i was trying to
fit in i was bet when i was 13 when i
moved there i moved there from florida
and i i just i wanted to fit in
and then when i went to high school i
was going to high school in boston or
in newton rather and all those kids had
that accident
so listen i've been having this
conversation a lot recently
do you think him and i definitely have
he has probably a little bit more of a
new york accent than me yeah do we have
a really
new york accent your accent is barely
new york i would say
educated east coast but not you don't
have like
the the accents are always like east
coast uneducated not educated on the
east coast well
i wouldn't no we actually do share some
words
in common like when i say the word all i
struggle with like it sounds like i'm
saying a-u-l-l-l
i sound like colin a little bit colin
quinn quinn yeah
yeah a little bit yeah i think so i
could see it a little bit we have a
similar kind of it's a rasp
little round of a rasp but much more
east coast with the accent
yeah probably the other the other word
i'm told is very new yorkish and how i
say it is florida
florida florida yeah how are you
supposed to say it
florida florida florida it's tightened
up a little bit on the live bedding just
so wait a minute what does this mean i
like how i like how that's our go-to
yeah
that's just moving people watching the
biggest thing it's not vegas it's
live yeah around two and a half to one
that's a [ __ ] big bet
i think it's all coming down to pa yeah
it is coming down to pa
let's see where pa is at now again it's
going to lean republicans
at the moment we're having a good time
over here
[Laughter]
i think it's it's still at 33 what what
is the best for avoiding violence in
this country
i mean leaving right right but honestly
in terms of like who wins
the best case scenario to avoid violence
i think
well it would have been a landslide
either way he's up here where there's no
seventy thousand nobody's fearing right
wing violence like
i think i think people i think people
are yeah yeah you know
yeah but the majority is i think people
are fearing if trump wins again they're
filing
wow that's uh i don't know man there was
a there was a a trump
like car parade by my place the other
day these [ __ ] were honking for
two and a half hours straight and
blocking the entire
that's happened slash cuomo bridge i
just think we we're always worried about
like the nazis and the white
the right-wing supremacist militias i
don't know that that ever comes
true in this country that's just the no
there's a meeting
does that happen because no there are
there are there are deaths from right
wing from
yeah but right look at the damage done
over the last six months
with political protests or political
riots i think 90
of it is left win yeah but well maybe
but hold on they tried to kill the
[ __ ] governor of michigan
we forgot nobody even tried they got
exposed the fbi probably put them up to
it
i've said many times that it seems like
they did it's true the guys were fbi
informants well maybe that's what the
people of michigan wanted the point is
this
i don't know i'm asking you if that was
a popular position
what's the initiative on it um but no
but let's be honest it's there's
this fantasy of that we're on the edge
of
you know all these right-wing militias
coming around it just does it's never
borne out by
the facts well it's a thing that they
like to repeat in the news like here's
one of them when
when uh chris wallace said to trump do
you denounce white supremacists
do you know this is like a [ __ ] video
compilation of trump denouncing white
supremacists yes
over and over
it's always like yeah i'll say the thing
you want me to say but i mean come on
the real problem is antifa and let's
only talk about it
that's not true no no in the video
compilation
there's multiple occasions where they
asked me to do that he goes absolutely
he was i denounced all hate
i denounced the kkk i denounced he he
says it over and over again right but
what did he say right after no listen
that chris wallace doesn't know that
that he's already said that that he's
pretending that he hasn't done it
it's kind of shameful for a guy who's
doing a debate i know that the media is
dishonest and i know that they do
exactly the thing
that you're accusing them of doing but
my point is you
he leads with that and then it's always
like oh yeah and by the way the left
wingers are the real problem let's focus
on the left wingers
not always but he has to say i've seen
him but but the left wingers when it
comes to these attacks like in portland
and the seattle
and a lot of the that is a lot of antifa
it's a lot of but the weird thing about
that is and
and i was talking to someone who
actually understands this stuff and he
was telling me listen
make no mistake about it that shit's
funded he goes no it's funded
and organized he goes it's funny they're
not idiots they're not they don't even
know because there's like the soros
conspiracy like oh there's big money
there's big money funding some pink
haired and purple haired college kids
who don't even know what the [ __ ]
they're doing and they're out there you
they can't even give you a real
political cause they're just burning
[ __ ] down
but that creates all sorts of turmoil
that creates turmoil and that
an erosion of our belief in our
democracy
right that's what i don't think there's
an ideological long game being played by
a purple-haired college kid i don't
think they're [ __ ]
doing i don't think they're a part of
the ideological long game i think they
said they were funded no no i said their
pawns
right but you were saying they were
someone wants this to happen someone
wants this deterioration
democracy that's a good question they
say george soros they say [ __ ] george
soros
because he's the [ __ ] boogeyman that
they always go why why do they always
say that because they're half
right because yes he is somebody who
funds
politicians and is corrupt but it's the
same thing with the koch brothers it's
the same thing with [ __ ] sheldon
adelson who just gave trump 75 million
dollars the other day
like yeah this is what they do but it's
weird and it's weird on the right and
the left when they single out
like one evil billionaire and make it
act like they act like oh that's the
real problem
no the problem is that all of them are
funding our politicians you know when
glenn beck was at fox
they told him there's two things that he
wanted us to talk about they wanted him
to stop talking about god
and they wanted him to stop talking
about george soros they said don't bring
up george soros
interesting glenn back towards the end
of his thing at fox kind of went insane
and started talking about the masons
a little bit and symbology and it was
some of the best television i've ever
yes with the chalkboard
yeah remember when he had that room
maybe had a nuclear reactor in his
basement like and then
would just be like why is this symbol on
the money it's like oh this is good
we're really getting to it now now we're
really getting it yeah
and then they took him out in a box well
he started doing his own thing online
and he was one of the first guys to be
super successful he was so successful
well he was a blaze there it is
with the blaze shields always the tides
and apollo the moon
was like this was the biggest scam ever
all the republicans were like people
were given cigarettes to vote for obama
it was such a [ __ ] thing
fox news did this for two months so like
people were given ripple and malt liquor
and
newport so they could vote for obama
it's like okay guys wait a minute can i
get a glass of water
yeah they were like uh yeah there he is
there it is yeah glenn beck really did
kind of lose his marbles towards the end
of the box
but it was getting good anytime
someone's drawing
that means they're in a good space
mentally so when he
left and went over to his own he did the
station
yeah the blaze was his network but i
think it went belly up something went
belly up because the blaze is still
around
but he bought out by i think ben
shapiro's people is that what it was i
think so
maybe but it was very successful for a
while
like he was i remember he was making
like 10 million dollars a month i was
like what
that guy's got issues i don't think he
handled the finances particularly well
which is why i think it kind of went
down what are you saying coke
drugs horse let's see uh he is the ceo
founder and owner of mercury radio arts
the parent company of his television
radio network the blaze
let me see the blaze i'm gonna type in
the blaze ben shapiro because i think
that they might have been working on a
deal
let me see daily daily wire turns five
years now
he's moving in nashville he's moving the
organization in nashville
he bailed out of california so yeah
i don't know why he why was he ever
there in the first place that's where he
grew up
oh he grew up a strong jewish community
he hates any sort of left-leaning
anything
a little bit yeah a little bit i'd say
have you ever met him
i've never met him no very very nice guy
i like him sure
no i don't know that's talk about ben
shapiro that's right ben shapiro i like
him a lot
he's a very nice guy he's a sweet guy i
saw him at a farmer's market once he's
like a small man
he's not that big yeah nice guy though
he's a very nice guy
he really is like uh you know we don't
agree on everything
but uh i never understood it's amazing
when somebody's like a guy like that's
dangerous i'm like just talk to him
ben shapiro ben shapiro's website is in
talks to buy glenn beck's the blaze but
i don't know if they actually did it so
the daily
talks versus daily wire you know what's
interesting like why would he want to
buy something
but you already got your own thing like
trying to expand consolidate
you know i'm gonna buy uh tim dillon's
going to hell and bring it back
please you can do it we want a boss
we're looking for a boss i'm looking for
sponsorship listen you all want
independence i want sponsorship
what kind of sponsorship are you looking
for anything the blaze the flare fish
daily water daily caller anything daily
the daily races let's see let's see what
the latest results are you hit me with
it
nothing much has changed something's
changed yeah i mean
and again we're not we're not going oh
it's getting tight 108 131
not getting a real accurate picture
because of the mailing situation stop
with the mailing i just i gotta
because i see everybody flipping out and
i'm like hey idiots they're counting all
the mailings first in certain places in
the count on all the regular votes first
gap in pa because that's hit this is
very big very low
no but that's this is all the on the day
votes stop
this is not the mailings where titan's
like seventy percent stop six point
communism that's a six point yeah how
what percentage of the state's votes are
mainland
i don't know the percent that's malin
but i do know that the breakdown is
going to be
60 to 70 percent biden in the mailings
understand but you've got
six points there that's a big gap so you
said it's 250 000 people right
that mail and vote didn't no no no no i
was talking about philadelphia
this is probably changing in real time
220 000 in pennsylvania
trump's gonna declare victory in five
minutes he's gonna he's definitely gonna
do that he's coming out
he's doing a victory in five minutes i
wonder when he could declare his victory
and whether or not
because john joe these are the states
these exact ones where trump is up yeah
the ones in the upper midwest
pennsylvania those are the ones
where we haven't counted the melons and
if he comes out and says hey it looks
like we're having a good night
what what the hell is going to happen
because he's going to try to stop the
vote there
do you do you have a little bit of
sadness that he's going to win again
sadness over trump winning i'm
i've been [ __ ] dead inside for the
longest time okay
kyle don't be thinking my [ __ ] job
my job joe rogan is to follow this stuff
every single day
you can't be the same person when you do
this this is what i would
one of the things that trump said is
that the the country was uniting this is
like his narrative the country was
uniting
before covid when he was starting to
like him because the economy was doing
well yeah yeah but i buy any of that no
of course not i told you that
even pre-coveted we had 78 percent of
the country was living paycheck to
paycheck
half of workers were making thirty
thousand dollars a year or less when is
that
was a mess when was has there been a
time when that wasn't the case in our
lifetime
our economy has always been bad but if
you're asking me for a model to point to
that i respect
i would say fdr the new deal the social
democratic
we're talking a different world during
our lifetime
has there ever been a time where people
were not living 78 weren't living
paycheck to paycheck like that i think
the further back you go it does get a
little bit better
because there were still the remnants of
the new deal era programs and
unionization yes exactly
that's exactly right exactly that's not
our lifetime no not during our lifetime
there's never been a time where people
have been
any better than they were than during
trump's admissions i mean maybe they
were slightly better in the 90s
but i don't know i've never seen data
for back then i can only tell you what
i've seen recently
what do you tribute like i know and i'm
not asking this because i'm trying to
prove anything i literally know nothing
about economics
what do you think was the reason why the
economy was doing so well at least on
paper
during uh the trump administration
before covid
why so you mean why is the unemployment
rate low why was it employment rate low
why was the stock market high why were
all these indicators
that trump was pointing to this is the
greatest economy the world has ever seen
so a lot of it had to do with uh the
2017 republican tax cut bill a lot of
had to do with his deregulation
because what happens when you deregulate
what happens when you cut taxes for the
wealthy in corporations
is you have this thing called a boom
bust cycle where everything kind of
takes off and it looks like everything's
amazing and oh my god look at these
indicators the unemployment rate is low
stock stocks are booming
but that's the problem is that it's kind
of fake and this is exactly what
happened in the lead up to the great
depression
you had the roaring 20s as it was called
because everything was taking off
oh my god the stock market's amazing
everything's great and then eventually
you have your day of reckoning it just
so happened that in our case
it was kovid that kind of popped the
bubble right kovid was the thing that
really was like
dude this thing is all fake anyway but
if it wasn't kovajo would have been
something else because just like in 2000
2008 is it safe to say that it's covered
because it wasn't
it wasn't real anyway because kova just
stopped people working dead in there
that's right no no that's right that was
a giant you know
issue that basically ground the economy
to a halt and there's no escaping that
you can't escape the economic reality of
that which is why what did they do in
response like we said
they did the cares act they took five
trillion dollars and they pumped it into
the economy they handed it over to the
corporations
and then they sat back and watched them
make these terrible decisions what could
be done
like let's say trump wins again what
could be done to bring the economy back
well first things first stimulus
immediately i would do a universal basic
income check
for the remainder of kovid if you're
going to do any sort of economic
shutdowns you have to pair that with
relief for people we we've
discussed this already but he obviously
is not interested in doing that
but he is he was going to do not ubi but
he was he did want to do another
stimulus bill do you think we have
seen mcconnell who were blocking him do
you think he has more freedom to do
anything if he wins again does he have
more freedom to do
is there any i'm looking for a silver
lining here
i mean listen the best he could do
because you're gonna have
a senate and a house that's not really
in line with him
okay so the best he could do is go all
out on the executive orders and do the
best you could do through that through
that path it'll be a four-year
kind of lame doc situation where the
congress and senate don't let him do
anything right it'll kind of be
he'll do some executive orders they'll
immediately be released uh
reversed when aoc uh wins and cuts
everyone's tick off
is that what she's doing well i believe
that she will be doing that because you
know what's going to
be the choice he's going to he's going
to win again probably maybe maybe maybe
not
but if he wins again it's swinging hard
like it's going to be ilhan omar and aoc
uh for the he's saying that see the
thing is i actually think it's gonna be
the opposite i think they're gonna go
further right wing i think they're gonna
go amy klobuchar i think they're gonna
go kamala harris
i think it's like i think the
establishment will have a stranglehold
even more on the democratic party 2024
don jr the empire continues wow i don't
know if i can take it
i don't know if i can take it what the
daughter and the son together ivanka is
a killer
do you think they could do that it's
over anyway let's let them try
so of the three of the three who's got
the most ability of the three who's got
the most ability
vodka i don't know i'm curious who you
think
of the three one of the three trump
kushner i don't know he's the son in law
i'm talking about the third
ivanka eric and don don junior eric
they don't let eric talk i think
something's wrong that's not true he's
on fox news from time to time
eric eric is tied with baron and then
you would have don junior and then
ivanka
i mean let's be honest don junior is the
best talker eric they tried to get
covered
i actually think eric has more promise
than don jr tell you the truth
tiffany you're right she's the forgotten
kid and i literally forgot her
i think we're alone now
[Laughter]
where is trump watching the results in a
gold
castle somewhere right underground no
he's at the white house
yeah they were gonna have a party has he
started jerking off yet
if i don't know man how many adderall is
he deep
four or five people are saying what what
you were saying which is like let's wait
for the marlins or is it kind of like
it's [ __ ] twitter they're all going
oh my god trump won it's already over
that's what i'm saying
hysteria and remember this is mostly
left-leaning twitter
is everyone racist now now here's what's
the question
what is the percentage of hispanic votes
that he got and african-american votes
that's fascinating
it was fascinating let me tell you
something with a little pump what the
numbers show already
is that he's doing better than he did in
2016 with them
i know he's gotten more he's got more
latinos and more black people than he
needed
the black conservative movement is not
covered at all by the media and you look
on youtube it's got hundreds of
thousands millions of views
is very interesting and the media
ignores it completely what do you think
what do you attribute that to
i mean he has like done some token
reaching out to them
i mean he just prison reform he was
doing a photo op with
little wayne the other day and then
before that he was doing one with you
know who was the other one little pom
poo he called little pimp
there's another one he called him a
little pimp yeah he's he brought him out
here can you get that up jamie yeah he
brings it up this is amazing have you
seen this
you have to see this you have to watch
this did he just not forget
he has no idea what's going on it's
correct no but he's
he does even better with latinos than
than he does with black people well
jorge mas vidal was campaigning for him
trump little pimp this is closing rally
it's so funny trump calls rappers you
gotta watch this
sound music and other things one of the
big superstars of the world
little pimp who's the president
it's not even little it's little it's
lil pump
he loves it he said little little pimp
little pimp that is hilarious
imagine if that was his name you should
come up with a character called little
pimp i should
little pimp listen it's a thought that's
not a bad character it's not a bad idea
that's a very good idea for you that's
not a bad idea your hair braided yeah
that's a little bit more a lot of
complicated fake face tattoos
cornrows yeah yeah and you could be
little pimp
it's interesting to watch um he's going
to come out tonight and definitely claim
sometimes i i do think that yes i do
think he's going to come out he says i
think
amazing what do you think now the odds
are that he wins um the odds are
definitely a lot better than they were
at the beginning of the night for sure
give me a number
i still think it's probably 65 chance
button wins
really yeah i do because a lot of what
you're seeing there
is attributable to what i said from the
very beginning which is they're counting
the votes that were in today first and
then the mail-ins come later how's he
not tweeting right now
after all the days he tweets and all the
times he tweets on non-stop
this is the time he hasn't tweeted for
we are looking really good
all over the country thank you he's
ready four hours ago that was
yeah but still saying we're looking
really good he's got to be happy
i just texted somebody with kind of a
little inside
information to see what's going on cia
no not cia somebody
who knows a little bit of uh what's
going on
deep state alex jones no the do you know
the kid from parkland who wanted more
guns yeah that guy yeah him
he's my inside sports biden fight in
windsor illinois
biden
no it's not it's just it's blue state
it's always a blue state
is it always a blue state i'm asking i
think yes i do think so he won
by yeah look at that that's pretty good
12 so uh
what's it at now what's the electoral
vote out now
131 to 108 how did he do how is he doing
with latinos
they don't have it split up on here
south carolina georgia
north carolina florida is florida still
in play what's the numbers in florida
now 1991 david updated it
interesting no he's got that yeah he's
up by 400 000. he's got that
it depends well i mean i think it's very
likely trump wins it
listen to you you communist no no i
think it's very likely he wins it but
it's interesting to see that he's making
has he made gains with latino voters or
we don't know that yes he's made gains
from his 2016 numbers yes
wow well there you go i mean they've
spent four years climbing
races every day it's actually really
it's actually the only one who didn't
listen was louis
gomez and that's and now and now
it's actually really interesting because
where biden took from trump
was old suburban white people okay yeah
because there's that's
where the bug his numbers from arizona
is showing for biden interesting sun
built yeah not good for him but no
that's going to
no wait a second arizona is going to
swing the other way it's going to swing
pro-trump as more votes come in
look at the numbers 53 73 already 45
oh it's 73 already okay so yeah you're
getting up there now
he's ahead by 208 by the way uh abc news
projects the democrats are going to
retain
control of the house representatives
that's not a huge surprise they were 97
favorites to do that anyway montana go
back to that so what's going on
what's going on that's a bunch of
californians moved to [ __ ] montana
that's what it is they all wanted water
aquafires and ranches they all wanted
ranches they wanted
taxes better too north dakota
interesting interesting thing here
so i'll tell you what here's the here's
the bad news i don't think we're going
to be getting an answer tonight
because if it wasn't florida going to
biden and being called
then it's going to go on because we're
not going to know pennsylvania for three
or four days
oh my god what chaos are we going to
have on the streets
well would you give trump eight minutes
he'll come out and say right we're doing
it really splendidly it's really amazing
it's really incredible
yeah you need to see this it's it's
really something else you've never seen
anything like this before
listen folks that we've never really
seen anything like this so i think i
think trump will he said he'll make some
type of statement tonight i don't know
what that what time is it east coast
right now
10 50. yeah i would imagine he's got to
make a statement within the next
hour right he's not going to speak after
midnight when you're on that adi son
time doesn't matter you know when you're
zuma that's a good point i know a fair
point
i think he's got he's going to come out
and declare victory within 15 minutes
yeah i would imagine before he goes to
bed yeah he's just going to come out
guys
i did this one tonight we respect you
i'd probably give him two
extra shots of steroids tonight just so
he could be and now where is kamala
and uh i'm sorry the [ __ ] is wrong
i apologize come along so
still in the basement they haven't told
them that the election started yeah
ma'am
because they got him they got him in a
hermetically sealed chamber where is he
you know who's you know who's smiling
somewhere is hillary clinton you know
she is i think so why didn't here's my
question why
didn't she run why didn't she run yeah
she's [ __ ]
incredibly disliked right but she won
the popular vote last time
yeah but actually yes queen her and
justly
maxwell just [ __ ] gone nuts she might
have won
when you lose there is a a period of
time where the country's like
[ __ ] off it's the opposite of a
bandwagon effect like we were talking
about earlier
because then you're just viewed as a
loser like happened with mitt romney
when mitt romney lost
for like a year and a half everybody's a
[ __ ] mitt romney get the [ __ ] out of
here because he was expected to win
actually versus obama
yeah i can't believe i never knew the
polling was that close with him
yeah that's crazy yep it was he was only
up 0.3 or something like that
that's crazy i'm i'm stunned by that
i just hope how are you feeling tim are
you good with this i'm good with it i
i tend to survive i think i'll be fine a
lot of people that i know and respect
are going to be very upset but they're
generally very upset about everything
yeah so i don't i if you can't be happy
then i don't know it's not my problem i
voted libertarian
i mean i didn't vote but go through joe
jorgensen i thought joe had a shot and i
don't know who she is i knew she didn't
know i don't know who she is or what she
stood for but i was very excited about
her candidacy legalizing drugs
good for her wait did you actually vote
for joe jorgensen
really yup i respect it i've done third
party votes before well i knew
california was going to
uh buy no matter what and i did not have
a voting plan
i was looking at the whole thing i was
like what is this i just i felt i know
the whole thing is just kumi had a great
line four years ago anthony kumi they
said
something something and then anthony
comey went listen trump
this doesn't the movie doesn't end with
trump losing
that was a great line that he had like
and everybody was like yo okay and he
was right
and i'm just wondering now seeing it as
a movie a weird cinematic thing what is
this
because i was sort of convinced that
this was biden's toulouse walking in
here and now it's like
oh it was definitely it was to lose like
the onus was on trump because he's the
one with the narrow path
we were fed a pile of [ __ ] yeah you were
right i think you've never been right
about this dude
no i'm sorry but the numbers were what
they were it's not like they were
fishing for that result
if anything but if you want to help
binding you say the opposite oh the
poles
are morons it's morons answering the
polls
i think i'm right they were jam right in
2018 though in the midterms they got it
exactly right 2018 bro this is 2020
and this is for the president but in the
midterms how many people vote
it's a small fraction it's obviously
lower turnout
gigantic difference right but if you
nail it with the data you nail it with
the date
but the the ramping up of the joe biden
[ __ ]
has been over the last few months it's
been really ridiculous
in in the sense that the media is
pushing it and this it says the media is
ignoring all that i just think that's
different from the polls ignoring all of
the corruption ignoring all the hunter
biden emails
all that [ __ ] with twitter where twitter
banned the new york post
where facebook was all true that stuff
was bad
all that stuff is bad no one thinks
that's a good thing
yeah but i feel like that i get your
point i agree with you i just think
perhaps we're too online in our own
world a lot of people are just [ __ ]
working their jobs and
making their decision when they see a
speech or two on tv you know what i mean
they're not following this [ __ ] in and
out like you and me
you're right but they heard about that i
know people that work regular jobs
said you hear about this twitter [ __ ]
and they were really upset about it
because they know that i've talked to
jack dorsey and i've had them on before
and that this twitter censorship thing
always skews left
like they always skew towards the left
listen and and censor i gotta push back
on that because the chapel trap house
reddit was banned i have a friend ronya
twitter
i'm saying social media i'm saying yeah
but we're talking about twitter okay
well there's reddit there's twitter
there's facebook i've seen censorship
twitter sent a lot of placements twitter
sense there's a lot of [ __ ] on on the
left as well
there's a unity 2020 which is sort of
central
centrist that's uh brett weinstein's uh
organization
where he was trying to get people on
both sides to come together and twitter
banned their account
which is [ __ ] preposterous facebook
banned their account but then due to a
lot of pushback facebook reinstated it
but then eric weinstein said you know
why are you lying and saying that this
was an accident like this is
manually reviewed by someone yeah
there's a
left outlet named jacobin and they had
they did
uh reporting on the election in bolivia
and that was polled because in bolivia
socialist won the election
and so they're socialists like even
smart
really smart people on the left guys at
chris hedges people like
that your friend abby martin they
understand yes she's been censored a
million times
all the critics of the state eventually
get censored so it's not left versus
right it's establishment versus
anti-establishment
and there's different flavors and
varieties of being anti-establishment
but
if you're speaking up yes you're
probably going to be in trouble well
abby's
censorship she gets a lot of pushback on
her stance on israel
right that's that's a big part of it
right last time she did
my podcast there was a tremendous amount
of it i'm sure of it but this is
something she's been dealing with for
the longest time and this is sensorius
trolls who want to shut her up because
they don't agree with her yeah yeah
there's a lot of that
there's a lot of that um but the thing
with twitter and the new york post was
particularly great oh it was
how are you gonna censor they're not
even making a claim of there's factual
inaccuracies
right they're not even saying that
they're just saying uh we think this
might be
election meddling or something because
maybe the information came from russia
well cnn one of the reporters for cnn
tweeted that it was russian
disinformation
no evidence of that whatsoever and by
the way even if it was
let's say this is the point that glenn
greenwald made he's a million percent
right
when you're a journalist if you're given
something newsworthy
you don't [ __ ] question the source
you say this is information that people
should know
it's like with chelsea manning and
julian assange when we learned that the
united states was drone striking
innocent people
and then they released that video that
showed us doing it and then became a big
story
if somebody said hey where did you get
that from did you get did the taliban
give that to you or did this person or
that person give you what the [ __ ] does
it matter
the information stands on its own two
feet like it's important in and of
itself
can you imagine if trump gets in for a
second term and then immediately pardons
snowden
and then pardons assange and then
legalizes drugs and then releases
the greatest rap album of all time with
real pimp with little pimp
he'll be a phenomenal i mean he could do
he's made a lot of peace deals that
nobody has talked about right that's
true
kushner's push like the sudan one i
found that hilarious because
israel and sudan were not at war so what
are you making peaceful it's not like
they were fighting
well they weren't fighting this is all
it's a show to be like oh yeah
vote for me i'm the [ __ ] no peace
deals that were exceptional
no the one thing i give him credit for
on foreign policy and i get a lot of
[ __ ] for this but i say because i think
it's true
is north korea because north korea
it is true that this this was a place
where obama was not able to get a deal
and trump basically went in there and
said i don't care i'll talk to him and
then he talked to him and
listen we're not at war we don't have an
official deal but i don't care we're not
at war and that's all that matters to me
the thing that's really interesting
though is isn't it weird how democrats
and republicans just casually flip their
position on the same
issue when it's different countries so
like obama
what obama did with iran is what trump
did with north korea
you know what i mean like obama wanted
to make peace with iran they did the
nuclear agreement
right and trump did the same thing with
north korea and then they flipped their
positions on the other
countries trump's kind of been masterful
with north korea whereas a lot of people
because you need a crazy guy
right because kim jong-un's a crazy guy
you need an equally crazy
psychopath and they kind of live a
similar look to them
yeah they sound they make these
bellicose threats but then they don't
really mean them
they're like a drunk uncle they wake up
the next day they're like they're
smiling
remember the rumors that he was dead and
the sister was running the show
great yeah what happened with that
because [ __ ] fake news is what
happened with that but it's just
they ran with those articles and it was
[ __ ] but was it was he putting that
out there to find traders
i don't know because people have done
stuff i don't know the mechanics of it
you know tyson fury did that in his last
training camp
what he put out rumors that his ankle
was broken
really yeah to find out if he's got some
rats inside his camp no [ __ ] yeah he
said he had an injury
yeah that's so weird and then i started
putting out pictures of the sister
yeah kim jong-un's sister yeah and then
we all got curious and then he came back
that was a great dramatic
tense moment people do [ __ ] like that
just to find out if they got rats in
their camp
right interesting yeah it's good just to
flush out the rats that's what uh tyson
fury did
yeah he had this feeling that somebody
was someone who was going down or if
that's why trump gave himself coven
he's like i just want to see who's just
got round give himself a little shot
yeah
what are you doing hello jamie do you
uh joe biden just won california i know
big shotgun
she literally just announced the whole
left coast for biden yeah that those
were all solid wait
a minute one california that's
ridiculous
it just hit the time so just eight
o'clock they're zero percent reporting
so i think they just caught them because
they just know rigged nevada got an
extra hour added on to it so
oh okay so arizona looks like it's going
blue what is arizona colorado what's
arizona now
is that unusual that arizona goes blue
wasn't arizona like a red state for a
long time
i thought it was going to be a lot
closer that's no you're exactly right
that arizona was a red state for a very
long time
but so but this is the thing in
california biden is polling well in the
sun belt because it's a lot of old white
retirees and that's who i was saying
before
that's where he took from trump he
didn't like trump is doing better among
latinos compared to last time
sorry go ahead no i was just saying that
trump was doing better among minorities
than he was last time
and biden is taking all of these old
white people from trump
go back to texas let me see texas
oh it's over it's over that's a big gap
in texas now
38 electoral votes that's going to bring
trump up florida's going to yeah see
that's what that's what texas should
i i was i thought he'd win texas i
thought trump would win tonight
florida's going to bring trump up
ohio's going to bring trump up it's
amazing how close texas is though isn't
it
ohio is going to bring trump up and then
pennsylvania here
everything here's what's going to happen
go to pennsylvania here's what's going
to happen
you're going to have it's very low still
you're going to have michigan and
wisconsin are going to flip blue and
then pennsylvania is really what it's
all riding on now
pennsylvania is 44 he's up by 400 dude i
think trump's wins pennsylvania
if trump wins pennsylvania he wins i
think he wins it i think he wins
there's a lot of steel a lot of fracking
a lot of steel uh what are the miners
there
that was very not
said that he was going available ban
fracking and yeah but he's videos
of fracking he's not what he wouldn't do
but it doesn't matter he said
he was going to ban fracking i think he
met on federal land specifically
but he said he never said he was going
to ban fracking
but he did and there's a lot of video of
it and so they caught him yes but i
think he's referring to federal land
specifically in other words i'm not
going to ban it for the whole country
he said he never said i know but they're
kind of misstating it because they want
to make it seem like oh he's going to
ban it all across the country no he said
i won't ban it on like federal or i will
banner on federal lands
which by the way listen we i live in new
york they ban fracking in new york
because they cause [ __ ] earthquakes
and they pollute the [ __ ] water
there's a real problem with fracking oh
yeah fracking i'm not a pro
fracking guy the one thing the front
like a little fracking one thing that
fracking's done that's good
is it's uh released our dependence on
foreign oil
yes but i do think we need to and barton
got a lot of [ __ ] for saying this but
it's absolutely true at some point we're
gonna have to [ __ ] get off the fossil
fuels
we can't do this forever right and biden
said by 2050 and people were
making a big stink about it like that's
crazy like really that's crazy what date
would you be okay with
20 60 20 70. do you think biden comes
out and makes a speech tonight do they
allow him to they don't let him talk
right it's over he never talks listen
for him they got to pump them up with
the adderall and they got to pump them
up with steroids what do you think they
pump them up with before that first
debate
could have been adderall could have been
seroquil it must have anti-psychotic
medication
yeah something something all of a sudden
he was lucid
in the debate with bernie sanders
organization that we have
where we have to pump the presidential
candidate full of anti-psychotics
before they go out isn't that isn't
there something wrong
it seems like there's something wrong
here i believe so
what's uh the antipsychotic do um
it takes him from being a psycho it's
seroquel at some antipsychotic mental
mother schizophrenic they may make you
all things like that like what is your
more clear thought
my friend's father used to take circle
he would like foam at the mouth and fall
down he was like a drunkard and that
and that happened but if he doesn't but
if he's not psychotic you still would
give him this
medication no i was largely joking when
i said oh i'd give him seroquel
but you know i thought you were serious
i thought it had like some adderall as
the adderall
thing that i would actually there's
still 2.2 million ballots to be counted
in pennsylvania about 87 percent of the
total yes so that means that
wow i think pennsylvania's gonna it's
biden i think
sorry really i don't know he was up six
points in the [ __ ] average of the
polls coming into today
it would have been a miracle if trump
pulled it off six points is way outside
of the margin of error 2.2 million is so
many
absenteeism six points is way outside of
the margin of error trump can maybe
swing at three points he can't swing at
[ __ ] six yeah but how many of those
two points a million
let's say seventy percent of them go to
biden right now there's how much there's
a big gap does it say well it's 2.2
million to be counted 2.2 million
that's 87 of the vote how long is that
gonna take
like i said four or five days maybe why
is there so many mailing ballots in
pennsylvania
because now since with kovid there's a
lot of places that have been doing
mail-ins and
everybody rushed to the polls to do
mail-in trump lost
do you see what happened right now trump
wanted any [ __ ] loss
we we are not going to know it's going
to be up to you for a long time
i like this election day and i hope it
lasts for six months
it's kind of crazy that there's like
this one state that could literally
yeah factor the whole thing now hershey
i'm sure i'm sure you remember this but
in the past
it wasn't pennsylvania it was it was
ohio did it a lot of times
ohio sometimes florida other times um
yeah sure so
you know 2000 it was florida and then
you had 2004 i think it was ohio they
put it over there there's never been a
situation like this where we're going to
go to bed not knowing who the president
is oh yeah there has been a
dangling chad's thing right well yeah
but i think even in more elections than
that there's a lot of ones many of them
go to sleep not knowing we know but we
kind of know
the carry one right uh carrie kerry kind
of lost i think comfortably actually
yeah we this one we really don't know
but a lot of them we would
you would go to bed not knowing but
there was a strong indication but wasn't
the carry one
was that the dangling chad's no that was
that was four thousand
al gore yeah though
he ran against bush and his argument was
all like yeah i'm going to keep doing
the iraq war too but i'm just smarter
than this guy
no no i mean there was something weird
about the election itself oh yeah there
was an issue with the voting machines in
ohio
it was like a private company that was
running them or something bold
documentary hacking democracy it's a
terrifying documentary that's not fun is
it
i mean listen just the fact that all the
states do it differently there's no
uniform
rules as to how to do this at the
federal level each state determines how
they're going to do their own election
yeah wildly different from state to
state different rules different time
frames
should we wrap this up i mean listen i
don't think we're gonna know
trump won and then he lost in this
podcast
i don't think they're gonna know joe
we'll never know yeah we may never know
people going to be mad at both of you
guys for not voting and me for voting in
a relationship joe jorgensen listen i
did what i had to do
i was going to vote i thought about it
and i looked at the people doing it they
said i don't want to be associated with
them so listen i just wanna
the i wanna reiterate this before we
finish and even though i said it about
78 times tonight
but we have the list of the states
michigan pennsylvania wisconsin virginia
they don't count the mail-in ballots as
they come in so they're counting all the
votes from today which are going to skew
pro-trump
and then after they count the mail-in
votes which skew pro-biden can we see
this the states again
so those states i think are in play
now let me ask you this is is there a
path
where if trump wins pennsylvania
where he could still lose the election
um let me see the map
let's see if he were if trump were to
win pennsylvania
and he wins ohio and he wins florida
um see his problem is he's not going to
win wisconsin and michigan i think he
might eke out
to 278 if he gets yeah if he gets north
carolina georgia florida pennsylvania
ohio i think that might get him there
but i thought he could win or excuse me
biden could win
without getting pennsylvania but it
would give him 270 exactly which is like
so tough what would that map be i'm
trying to i can't i can't check the
tweet because you guys are i have to get
it right
look at that two seven you can win
it real as of right now it really all
rides on pennsylvania because i'll tell
you what
michigan and wisconsin are not going to
stay pro trump they're 100 flipping
abiding because he's up like eight to
ten points there in the polls
and we haven't counted the mail-ins yet
so wisconsin and michigan are gone for
biden for sure
so it's going to come down to
pennsylvania
and arizona too a little bit but it
looks like biden's going to hang on
there which is kind of surprising looks
like he's winning it
that's what i'm saying it comes down to
pa arizona is another [ __ ] state
where the californians fled to
they all went to phoenix and tucson but
it's more old suburban
retirees yeah what i mean we're not
gonna like
arizona scroll down let me see next
factor if michigan and wiscons
scroll back up disagree that michigan
and wisconsin go to biden as the
candidates have ex
campaigns have expected then
pennsylvania takes center stage right
not necessarily
biden could lose pennsylvania and still
win the presidency if he wins arizona
plus maine two and nebraska two he's not
going to win
not split those two no no a main second
district that's not the same as maine
oh it's it's actually much more likely
it would be too 70 on the nose
interesting yeah but i
um it's i think it's going to come down
to pennsylvania
wow what a tight race it's a tightrope
do you think trump's not going to raise
[ __ ] hell if he's got 268.
trump's not going to let that [ __ ] go
he's going to be what can he do supreme
court
he'll say [ __ ] it fraudulent this that's
fake this isn't real that's where it
gets ugly right
that's where we have a real problem in
this country yeah well it goes to the
supreme court remember those people that
tried to knock the biden bus off the
road yes yeah
imagine how they're going to react if
they think that democrats
going to try to steal it there was a
bunch of [ __ ] that was happening i don't
know if you saw the violence in north
carolina today where people
were trying to block the polls there was
a lot of
chaos and police were pepper spraying
people at the polls
yeah it didn't look good doesn't look
good it looked awful it's like
god damn it this is voting is there a
shot that we don't know the answer
tomorrow
yes there's a very good job we don't
know the answer tomorrow because it
might take a while
what do you think if you had a guess if
i had to guess
i think it looks relatively close i'd
say
three days maybe we might know the
answer god so the weekend
perfect time i'll tell you right now
flying the
[ __ ] out listen yeah you're you're
getting out
under the wire i'm getting out tomorrow
at 6 30 a.m it's perfect smart
go right back to the desert pack your
[ __ ] get ready to move here
yeah it's common not immediately it's
coming we'll see it's coming
i got to see this might go blue oh look
at this man we'll see
no i think i think trump said there's a
potential
it's probably very hard but a potential
tie of 269 each
it seems like to get okay that would be
something for the country
no idea what happens there like no then
they slug it out yeah then they fight
duel
do you imagine if there was a let me
tell you it comes out of the basement of
the white house rises up
they climb in and duke it out with uh
those [ __ ] unboxings there was this
thing
there was only a four percent chance it
would end like that and it seems like
that might happen
what happens in what in case of a tie
yeah they review
it goes to congress hold on let me look
because this says that
the this is from 538 who is everyone's
favorite account today because the polls
but
it says in that case biden would need to
carry either nebraska or maine's second
congressional district to win and i
don't know why
those two specifically um
i'm gonna look i actually don't know
what happens if it's a tie and i'm gonna
look now does nancy pelosi default
or something
in the united states a contingent
election is the is the procedure used to
elect the president or vice president
in the event that no candidate for one
or both of these offices wins an
absolute majority of votes in the
electoral college a contingent election
for the president is decided by a vote
of the united states house of
representatives congress decides
well a contingent election for the
president for the vice president is
decided by a vote of the united states
senate oh my god that's interesting
because that would mean the democrats in
the house would pick biden to be
president
and then the republicans in the senate
would pick a republican to be vice
president and then what the
supreme court picks so the default does
it go first during a contingent election
each house state delegation casts
one vote to determine the president
rather than a vote from each
representative senators instead cast
votes individually for vice president
the contingent election process was
first established in article 2 section 1
clause 3 of the u.s constitution
it was subsequently modified by the 12th
amendment in 1804
the phrase contingent election is not
found in the text of the constitution
itself
but has been used to describe the
procedure since at least 1823.
wait so i i just i read over that real
quick and you kind of glossed over it
says that the president and vice
president are
indirectly elected so that means they
pick them they each
are picked separately right that's what
i just said really
i know it's going so fast this is a very
bad system i said
i said you have the congress picks the
president and then it's the senate that
picks the vice president
the senate is republican right now and
congress is
democratic right now she would have a
democrat at the top of the ticket and a
republican at the bottom
i think you'll have a winner i think
it's just going to be somebody's going
to win somebody's going to win these
things
i think it's going to all come down to
pennsylvania and i still think it's very
likely biden wins pennsylvania because
they got to count all the mail-in
ballots and they're overwhelmingly biden
but but i will say this listen if
if biden wins this election and he's got
less than 300 electoral votes
yet again trump outperformed the polls
he absolutely outperformed the polls
because all the polls coming into today
if you just copied and pasted
it would have been biden 351 electoral
votes
so that means trump outperformed the
polls yet again if biden only wins with
like 278 or some [ __ ] so with
pennsylvania and they're mailing votes
like how
carefully are those going to be
monitored like the counting of them
this could get really weird it can get
really weird it can get really ugly we
know trump is probably already going to
try to downplay them and get them
dismissed
the republicans are literally they're
doing lawsuits in certain states to try
to get the balance
of the state voting absentee covin
covid a lot of states have been doing it
like that where a lot of people don't
want to show up
seems odd to me because you can go to
the grocery store you can go somewhere
else i don't know why you can't
pull a lever yeah that seems odd
seems odd there are they're going to be
lawsuits where they try to pennsylvania
won't finish counting absentee ballots
till friday at the earliest
oh that's a long time they're busy
dealing with tuesday's in-person voting
wow friday that's nuts so here we are on
tuesday wednesday
thursday and then friday three days like
i said oh my god
wow when pennsylvania approved
so-called no excuse absentee mail
ballots last fall
meaning any voter can request one
without citing a reason the law
didn't allow officials to begin
canvassing mail ballots until polls
close on election night according to
lisa shaffer
the executive director of the county
commissioners association of
pennsylvania
by the way if biden loses the democrats
will immediately blame
the voters as if the voters let him down
not that he wasn't a good enough
candidate
because this is exactly what happened in
2016. they immediately started blaming
the voters
yeah well they're going to be bitter you
know
people when they lose they blame all
kinds of [ __ ]
other things other than their own
performance well hey
we had a few filet of fish yeah we tried
we had a few laughs
if people think that we weren't taking
things seriously you're right that's
what we're doing
that's exactly what we're here for
correct this is not a
serious uh election show um but uh thank
you gentlemen
thank you for having me that was a lot
of fun indeed yeah thank you for coming
and explaining things to us my pleasure
that's like you're welcome informed no
that guy
uh thank you for mocking our
our system thank you jamie for being a
big snopes fan
appreciate that michelle
[Laughter]
jamie's uh he's a coped survivor
give him some respect i know i kind of i
kind of shimmied away from him when i
saw him at the door
i was like all right are you good bro
he's got the antibodies
he does he's the most safe person in
this [ __ ] that's right he's a cough
in his mouth and he'd
brush it right off um all right well
that's it ladies and gentlemen thank you
for tuning in i hope it didn't
disappoint you too terribly
i hope you're not mad at me for voting
for someone who can't win good luck and
enjoy the riots i hope you're not
imagining dylan and kyle kalinski not
voting at all
yeah chaos it's going to be chaos coming
up in the next few days yeah i hope i
really think it is
boy i hope we can get through this as a
country and um
and uh but listen on the bright side
more people voted than ever
which i think we're aware now that's a
great point the importance of voting
tim dillon show on youtube good luck tim
dillon has a great show
you can watch his podcast secular
talking secular talk
on youtube yeah well that's i was going
to get to that eventually
talk over tim dillon's plug
tim dillon also is on the road he's
hitting the road again starting to do a
lot of gigs
yeah we're trying we're seeing they're
cutting capacity we're rescheduling some
stuff but we're going to win this fight
through it
killed those chicago shows they're just
killing them left and then they're also
like going like hey
some of these clubs like how about doing
24 shows said i'm like no no let's wait
two months
so we'll see well thank you guys thank
you thank you bye everybody
peace peace on earth and good will to
everybody